peu
[Musique]
alors t'as vu ce qui se passe là tous
ont de quoi tu me parles tu rigoles ou
quoi la radio ou à la télé les journaux
tout le monde enfants a le truc mais oui
ce matin je suis allé au précis
m'attends à tout moment pas à l'autre
c'est foutu c'est que j'ai eu trois
courants en ligne lance à fond tu aurais
parlé aussi bios et enfin oui lui aussi
passifs ils en parlent ça veut dire que
tout le monde amis du samedi soir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez l'équipe ouais si linda
hardy
[Applaudissements]
certes ça va bien bien alors ce que nous
allons accueillir maintenant comme
beaucoup de duos ils sont deux et à 2100
drôle comme personne la sica les
olivières
canaliser mon soir
ça termine
flamatt mon sens aucun accueil alors on
va commencer par petite promo et après
on fera grosse promo d'accord d'accord
petite promo oui la grosse émission tous
les soirs sur comédie à 19 heures à 19
heures voilà ça y est j'ai bidouillé mon
en visio passer ça y est arie enfin ça y
est en fait je l'avais mais je savais
pas y aller voila voila c'est vachement
bien maladroit voilà la paillote tous
les matins vous participez à la paillote
c'est sûr horreur 2 oui à quelle heure
sur trop 6h et 9h et nous on passa
séchée sur cette ville où je sais plus
nombreux on entre 6h et 9h sont tapés
l'émission pour tomber à un moment de
bien et alors le courtepaille leur
concours le 31 décembre
c'est vrai le 31 décembre voilà alors
après on fera grosse promo 1 sera père
noël chez auchan les 21 et 28 décembre
si ça a été juste ce succès donne tout
et berne le lien porte alors mise à part
kad et olivier nous recevant ce soir
anne parillaud
jean luc mélenchon
[Applaudissements]
météo
mais alors
michel de paix
alors ils attaquent
et fabrice tiozzo
voilà alors maintenant c'est le moment
le moment clé de l'émission oui du début
de l'émission c'est quand on voit ce
qu'il y avait de mieux la semaine
dernière donc l'émission avec pierre
palmade avec jean d'ormesson un
supérieur et voit la super mission donc
on regarde ça s'appelle tout le monde en
a parlé magnéto da vous préfériez avoir
une tête de veau ou un bras de 9 m un
bras de 9 m non mais j'y vais parce que
la tête de veau bon d'accord vous gardez
votre voix j'espère me voir un jour vous
vous dites bonjour normalement raté
quand même produire bonjour qu'est la
dernière chose que vous faites avant de
vous coucher
je ferai un lexomil moi c'est pas très
original mais quoi je vais pas vous dire
que ça fait quoi si vous êtes déjà senti
une [ __ ] soit 180 une semaine si
vous fait si j'avais décidé de pas me
parler de scooter mais donc ça c'est pas
nous parler de vos pieds nus quand plus
de moins en moins le cas de pas vous
parler de vous originaux cristaux
pratique la poitrine les grandit de 17
cm ans quand même temps alors non
maintenant évidemment la polaire il n'a
pas suivi
forcément il ya des modèles ce qui est
petit est précieux vous avez déclaré une
fois je suis à 100 dons sur le manière
oui j'aurais pu dire liban d'où truite
saumonée enfin ça dépend des fois c'est
vrai quoi il se fait partie du clan des
ces jolies il y en a oui je vous le
confirme
non vous avez déclaré au sujet de ce
clip vous étiez tout nu même si on sait
que de temps en temps at il va se fripe
ôter le schmilblick
c'est pas très grave j'ai dit ça à judy
vraiment avril sur garanti pur porc
alors donc si vous êtes chez vous sortez
votre chemise critiquent l'accord ne
sais quoi c'est existe peur de défini
pour nous non c'est bien il n'aime pas
du tout les 4 septembre
est-ce que la porno phobie c'est quand
on a peur de l'acte sexuel
c'est marrant non tout de suite c'est à
vous qui parlez nous on n'existe plus
ah je vois bien vous êtes un peu jaloux
non mais non vous avez vous avez
déclarez vous avez déclaré les premiers
les premiers livres on les écrit
toujours pour plaire aux filles oui
inscrits mais au nom non dit vas-y c'est
une remarque je sais pas où je vais vous
vous savez le le coup le plus classique
qu'on fait c'est jouer arrivée les
jeunes filles ravissantes qu'il faut
faire dédicacer un livre est la phrase
classique était ma mère a tellement
d'admiration pour toi et puis ça a
changé il ya quelques temps et c'est ma
grand-mère et l'on doit jeter chez
gallimard raconte cette histoire et à ce
moment là y'a une stagiaire qui entre
ravissante charmant et je vous assure qu
elle a dit je crois que vous êtes à
l'année devant le gardien un jour je
suis invitée avec greta garbo
on est trois tables et mme jany à
beaucoup un tas darbo et puis prix d'une
espèce de folie je me met à chantonner
le pinphone koffi source aof riber est
ce que ça dit quelque chose je suis de
les pieds à la tête
oui et c'est la chanson de l'ange bleu
ouais je sais comment la mélodie voilà
un pin à vous voulez vous faire chanter
sens premier du terme qu'on puisse faire
ça au plus bas à neuchâtel
je chante sa great à gogo elle fit pas
mot et vous êtes comme on insiste quand
on fait des gaffes et j'ai dit j'ai
tellement aimé l'ange bleu n guerrière
j'ai dit je vous ai tellement admirée
dans l'ange bleu et surtout envers moi
et me dit je vois que vous me prenez
pour marlene dietrich plus tard je dîne
à côté de mme allende
vraiment on s'entend bien on s'entend
vraiment bien et elle me dit même ce qui
était assez rare elle me dit venez me
voir
j'habite avenue montaigne je crois que
la [ __ ] est vraiment un auteur et je lui
dis je vais vous raconter une histoire
tordante je lui raconte cette histoire
elle m'a tourné le dos elle m'a plu quel
est le couple qui vous choque le plus
une femme mûre avec un homme jeune de
femme ou un homme âgé avec une midinette
sûrement parle pour dire c'était donc
on en parlait le meilleur de l'émission
de la semaine dernière voilà alors
maintenant grosse promo pour kad et
olivier
voici ce qui se passe un best-of de ce
qui se passe tous les soirs sur comédie
à 19h dans la grosse émission magnéto
serge la leçon de cinéma de kad et
olivier
leçon numéro 2 peut-on mettre autre
chose que des violons sur une scène de
baiser
[Musique]
isabelle paul je t'aime
sa chasse
m
non on ne peut pas mettre autre chose
que des violons sur une scène de baiser
ils sont beaucoup plus nombreux que
prévu jean ferrat mais qu'est ce que tu
vas faire mac
j'ai été dans de sales draps les
guérilleros du colonel de la guarda
n'allais pas me lâcher de sitôt
en plus je ne devais pas décevoir ma
partenaire que j'ai compté [ __ ]
avant la fin de l'épisode ce que tu
deviens la marque
non non rien jennifer lorsqu'on sac je
n'avais à ma disposition qu'une vieille
boîte d'allumettes usagers une pomme de
terre un bocal de cornichons et un vieux
jeu de master mind abandonné dans la
poubelle de la ville de paris ça
n'allait pas être facile
qu'est ce que tu comptes faire avec ça
mc nous sauver la vie de jennifer
[Musique]
la partie du match et si mac gyver avait
été con je n'aurais jamais connu les
plaisirs de l'amour annales
vous êtes avec nous ou ailleurs je sais
pas maintenant je le vois ça y est c'est
vrai j'ai vu il y en a d'autres
il y en a d'autres moins drôle que vous
mais bon non non non ça se défend si
vous allez retourner là bas bonne
ambiance
qu'est ce que vous avez dit core dix ans
vous aviez fait à rien bon alors non
mais vous êtes vraiment en ce moment ça
marche pour vous un bon puisque sur les
filles quoi pas on peut dire que j'ai vu
en plus c'est la misère de le pas ce que
je veux de belfort 90 et ouais c'est la
plus belle femme moi je me suis dit que
c'était pour toi pour moi que tu avais
mis ça non c'est aussi pour toi c'est
d'abord dresser pour vous et puis parce
que si linda voulait montrer à notre
public à nos amis du samedi soir qu'elle
avait pris un peu de ça si on a pris
trop arrête maintenant je vais vous
laisser mes amis dans les mains de linda
hardy enfin jouer à jeu mais aussi moins
c'est cher
je vous donne ça s'appelle alors tendez
linda oui ça s'appelle le qui a dit
linda qui est oui et puis il faut
surtout baisser la lumière ne bouge pas
avoir un jingle
c'est bon c'est pas mal ils peuvent bien
sûr mais là vous aviez maintenant la
paix mal c'était génial
bon là commence alors le qui a dit donc
je vous donne des phrasés vaut essayer
de trouver qui a dit cela mais quelle
animatrice de télé a dit le massage des
fesses est aussi essentiel qu'un
shampooing sur les cheveux carlos mais m
claire chazal animatrice si matrix
matrix 2
pascal sevran c'est aussi et fonctionne
400 points sur les sofitel janvier bras
[Applaudissements]
que l'animateur de télé a dit mon
fantasme qu une très jolie femme
un véritable asberg se jette sur moi à
peine entré dans un taxi manu dibango
non je ne sais pas si ça c'est pas du
mazout sûr que non et là mes mates
heures de france 2 alors que foncia n'a
pas beaucoup de gens pensent de la
défausse de faisabilité relative manche
est relativement jeune
actuellement jeanne de longues mèches co
n'ont pas je ne sais pas mais vous ne
jamais essayer enfin j'aurais eu peur
oui bien c'est celui qui nous faisait
jouer avec les petits
vous laisser dépasser 4 qu'est l'être
quelle actrice de séries américaines a
dit je ne suis accroc ni à la boisson ni
à la drogue
ma seule drogue c'est le sexe j'aime le
sexe et j'aime les hommes
les martin circus a compté depuis le
début s'est passé mais j'ai bien kiffé
américaine s'est pas mêlé
mais ce site comme ella qui écoutent pas
bon suivi les 216 goûter comédienne
française de sitcom a dit je refuse les
scénarios dans lesquels je mange une
biscotte à poil dans la cuisine à 3
heures du matin les bouts d'os des
tombes des morts guy bono au pardon
thierry geiger s'est passé pas mal riz
afin non non c'est pas la joie
c'est pas loin c'est hélène rollès ah
c'est pas loin dans plus c'est pas une
rolex donc c'est moi mexico elle était
mannequin elle était mannequin elle
était mannequin était mannequin elle
aussi pas mal a été le cas vanessa
à temps j'étais pas mal
ouais c'est vrai vous êtes au courant
jo brohan je regarde la télé d'accord
auquel présentateur français a dit je
n'ai plus du tout le même rapport avec
les femmes depuis je fais de la télé
j'ai l'impression que certaines essaie
de se servir de moi pour leur propre
carrière
pompidou les arbitres sont pas c'est pas
toi qu'à 17 yens 1,1 dans les shales
michel strogoff on était à côté toi ce
soir dans une autre émission oui il est
sur la chaîne histoire voilà il fait
noir et julien lepers là qu'est ce qu'on
fait c'est quoi c'est quoi tu sais comme
indice télé c'est pas moche animateurs
non non non en plus je ne bouge pas donc
au juge
voilà moi j'ai trouvé par hasard
[Applaudissements]
ça leur fera du cadam ans l'émission
j'ai bien ce jeu un jeu amusant comme
jeu intéressant non mais c'est parce que
comme dans une coulisse ils nous ont
fusé du champomy suis un peu chez moi
mais ça y va fort ici nous la semaine
dernière n'avait palmade qui carbure au
lexomil qu'elle très belle actrice
blonde american a dit je suis folle de
sexe et l'infidélité chez moi est une
vocation
je sais je sais la jeune âge en plus oui
je te l indice elle a fait un film we
show elle a few johnstone je me dis pas
je viens moi c'est moi et cet enlèvement
on va faire comme thierry je devrais
dire si vous continuez à souffler
j'évacue la seule moi je dis pas ça les
jeux j'ai face à moi et je ferai tous
les passages effectués moi j'ai vaincu
jamais un petit public l'asie continue
de redire et était coiffé cherche pas
aujourd'hui la séparation c'est ça ne
rame non modifiée
c'est un parent nom ne vous dit ce
n'était pas nouveau chemin des visions
disant que c'est pas dix ans c'est à
dire si c'était vraiment bien ça fait
d'annoncé en 91 donc politiques français
a dit pour moi la femme idéale c'est
celle de l'ancien temps durera la peine
qui sert les hommes à table gérard de
villiers je ne cesserai jamais avec eux
et surtout ne parle pas 2545 francs
c'était là juste prix est pas ça
s'annonçait pas je suis à la rue comme
ça
le pen c'est incroyable c'est un type
qui avait un truc quand il ya eu la pac
en gouvernement a décidé la parité le
même personnage a dit oui la parité mais
[Applaudissements]
c'était un moment très fort tout moment
je peux faire des cascades dans
l'intéressante elle s'appelle la
casquette du tabouret renversé alors est
ce que vous avez trouvé
je vous demande de vous arrêter ça dure
la dure crise non je crois qu'en affaire
aille beaucoup plus loin dans les ped
d'après mike les garder c'est moi avait
dit ça c'est moi la thur et je ne sais
pas encore ce que je vais tomber
donc pour l'instant j'ai la griffe le
droit je regarde gens regardent les
niches haut de 2 je regarde la
discussion est le plus petit et linda
regarder ce qui se passe je suis
hypnotisé
[Applaudissements]
en fait voilà je vous demande de vous
arrêter au néolithique qui a dit cette
phrase que j'ai extrêmement machiste
l'autre jour quand le gouvernement a
décidé de faire la parité il a dit oui
mais encore faut-il qu'ils aient 50% de
femmes c'est bien mais encore faut-il
qu'elle soit éligible
c'est pour vous dire à quel point il a
non à quel point il a deux discours à
quel point il a deux discours c'est
quand même pour les classes de dire sa
mère relisez nous la phrase des jeunes
déjà je ne pour moi la maîtrise et la
création avec une intonation joue la
police après que cela ferait avec la
vraie phrase sa vraie rentrée c'est pour
moi la femme idéale mais c'est celle de
l'ancien temps durera la peine qui sert
les hommes à table qui leur servent des
pommes ne s'assied jamais avec eux ne
parlent pas c'est parce quoi que dise ah
non non et h au pom's à la fin il
fallait faire tous ces chiffres
[Applaudissements]
sur un ticket c'est bon de rallumer les
lumières sombres soudaine de ce qu'elles
rentrent à la
[Applaudissements]
et dites moi c'est le numéro de
téléphone de notre ami brune avec les
bottes noires que vous voulez la non
absolument sinon faut le dire
franchement je dirais fois je préfère
que vous me regardez cette émission vous
donne de meilleurs jours je salut public
qui m'a aidé pendant le jeu dynamique et
ça c'est pas gagné
c'est pas gagné six combats non non je
suis 100 mains c'est bon tu saches
c'était j'attends l'amour c'est un plomb
je vous demande de vous avez été j'avais
matin nous allons recevoir que c'est pas
mal non
on va recevoir l'une des actrices du
nouveau film de claude lelouch qui
s'appelle une pour tout et qui sort le
1er janvier 2000 elle s'appelle anne
parillaud
enfin le bon soir
les séquelles galibier où le oui je te
la donne en plus qui sont très drôles et
j'en ai beau pull et surtout olivier ça
fait plaisir en tout cas merci c'est
gentil notion causé 9 061 année encore à
parler du film
d'abord on apprend par un peu de vous
donc dès inquiète quand je veux dire par
là un peu de vous oui j'aime pas trop ça
non mais très légèrement vingtaine de
minutes pas plus donc une pour tous de
claude lelouch sortie le 1er janvier
2000 avec alessandra martinez marianne
denicourt avis et 26 olivia bonamy jean
pierre marielle samy naceri et vous bien
sûr oui je passe l'histoire vous la fête
on l'a fait je serais d'accord téléfilm
non bon ok c'est la d'histoire les
vachement bien donc c'est facile a
raconté il ya des films c'est dur là
c'est ça dont je vous la raconte à vous
la connaissez vous êtes tourné le film
bon je raconte l'histoire il ya une
olivia bonamy vous connaissez pas encore
olivia bonamy si vous la connaissez
alors donc olivia bonamy elle bosse air
france elle fait l'embarquement pour le
concorde et alors il ya trois amis trois
soeurs pardon qui sont les amis qui sont
marianne denicourt alice evans et anne
parillaud qui font les trois soeurs de
tchekhov et puis bon ça se passe pas
très bien la tournée elles ont besoin
d'argent var était de 6 me trompe son
besoin d'argent tout ça et ils font un
coup c'est là le loup c'est un peu comme
l' aventure celle aventure quoi donc
les filles elles les asseoir à côté de
mecs riche et donc c'est très bien
préparés parce qu'ils savent elles
savent à côté de qui elles vont être
assise donc si par exemple c'est un type
qui quitte un grand chef d'orchestre qui
joue du bach tout le temps ils ont bien
failli y arriver à ce genre de ses rangs
tous ses écrits la vie arrive elle dit
on verse un truc sur le genou ça qui
commence elle engage la conversation
et puis elle dit comment elle s'appelle
elle dit ben je suis l'arrière arrière
arrière petite fille de
jean ses bottes chant sébastien c'est
incroyable je suis le chef d'orchestre
qui joue voilà c'est ça oui c'est rigolo
donc à l'e3 on voit l'histoire quand
exactement la même idée donc ouais bon
séparemment la laisser à klose est donc
en fait toute l'histoire et raconter
cette histoire là donc on voit
évidemment dans le sine
mais c'est un film dans le film parce
qu'en fait c'est un auteur un flic qui
écrit comme tous ces flics et des romans
policiers impliqués a écrit ça qui est
joué par jean-pierre marielle excellent
et le l'assistant de jean pierre
marielle
si samy naceri et c'est assez rigolo à
passer en même temps c'est un peu fine
dans le film c'est un peu pire ont des
liens non c'est ça tombe bien c'est moi
je trouve ça vachement très le chien
lellouche estime je dirais pas le chien
lellouche ici vous voulez veine on sera
curieux de voir ce film bien sûr
commencent à filtrer sursis pour avoir
un ne parions qu'ils sont un petit peu
rare je peux me permettre à nos trois
périodes joue olga donc un et vous
parlez nous un peu du personnage c'est
un personnage très humain enfin c'est
pareil j'ai beaucoup de mal a résumé le
personnage quand j'ai du mal a résumé
les films je suis j'ai plus de facilité
à dire ce que je ressens plutôt que dire
ce qu'ils sont et pour moi c'est un
personnage extrêmement humain qui essaye
de conserver ses rêves ses espoirs ses
enthousiasmes au milieu d'une jungle
avis et de est en fait cessé
c'est une comédienne comme l'expliqué
thierry et c'est vrai que ça montre à
quel point pour une comédienne quand on
est passionné on est prêtes à aller
jusqu'au bout on est prêtes à huy a
frôlé la prostitution c'est pour
permettre de vivre
[Rires]
on va envoyer la bande annonce du film
puis on continuera à discuter après
magnéto écoutez il n'aime pas les
blondes si vite fini s'il faut posséder
tout moisi
[Musique]
est ce que pour une simple tu peux pas
appeler un chat un chat une [ __ ] une
[ __ ] aurait coûté les figures j'essaie
de trouver des solutions pour payer vos
dettes
ouais bah moi je continue à penser que
ça s'appelle le plus vieux métier du
monde
à vous de rajeunir tout le temps comme
ça mais sa voyance est au coeur du film
comme quand les femmes ne peuvent pas
répondre à nos questions qu'est ce
qu'elles font qu'est ce qu'il faut et
les pleureurs et dans le film on les
voit s'entraîner à pleurer pour pleurer
sur commande
je me faisais une telle mesure d'aller
en afrique c'est vous c'est moi ce
olivia le topic celui-ci mais si je te
connaître il est donc moins il faut
chanter sous ce qu'on essaye de dire un
film c'est que depuis depuis depuis la
nuit des temps tout à fait des progrès
mais pas l'amour alors là vous pensez
que d'escroquer des mecs dans un
concorde ça va dans le sens du progrès
alors vous avez pensé à mettre en scène
et là vous avez une petite idée vous
pourriez conseiller quelqu'un mais il
fait ses ses propres films mais ce n'est
des crises histoire ça te coûte une
fortune louche non mais là le dirigeant
habite on devrait l'avoir pour rien
[Musique]
une porte de sortie dans les jambes
depuis 2000
alors on voit là l'ambiance est très
rigolo c'est plein d'humour plein de
deuxième degré c'est en couleur océan
bleu alors voilà et alors on découvre
alice evans et nathalie à oui elle avait
joué dans monsieur navteq et elle était
daisy disneyland pendant huit mois
l'ouverture à des gens connus qui ont eu
ces dix matches à cheryl était unique et
d'accueil aussi oui bah oui mais là
j'avais l'image est bien alors vous
dites je ne n'ai pas de plan de carrière
je tombe amoureuse d'un personnage d'un
film d'une vie d'une autre vie c'est
vrai vous choisissez des films comme ça
à l'instinct vous n'avez pas sur ça je
tombe pas souvent non c'est vrai parce
que je suis je suis en fait je me sens
pas actrice je me sens quelqu'un qui
sous une inspiration peut essayer de
donner quelque chose un personnage et de
le servir d' essayer de partager son
inspiration est quelqu'un avec le public
avec et si je suis pas inspiré je suis
incapable de rien mais vous dites
d'ailleurs le métier de comédienne ça me
permet de survivre dans une société où
je ne trouve pas ma place
c'est une façon d'échapper à un système
qui ne signifie rien pour moi
michel charasse oui c'est une question
de quelles sont les valeurs qui sont
défendues dans une époque dans une
société et qui correspond pas forcément
à celle qui pour moi prédomine où sont
les plus importantes mais plus les frais
les plus primordial ce serait quoi pour
vous présenter la société idéale une
société vrai que la suite est pas mal
non
je vous embête oui enfin ça m'embête
non je la juge pas mais moi je trouve
pas ma place du coup parce que oui j'ai
la sensation d'être à civray temps ce
que je veux faire dans ce que je veux
dire dans ce que je vais essayer de
faire passer et j'ai du mal à j'ai du
mal dans sa société ou sais pas si pas
le
c'est pas le langage qui parler vous
êtes vous réfugier dans la fiction parce
que finalement vous trouvez pas votre
place dans la réalité vous suivez les
garçons avec un match tous yahia il ya
trop de volcans par exemple les
frontonnais
dites moi alors vos débuts dans le
métier c'est je sais pas si c'est une
légende ou pas une légende de nous dire
parce que vous êtes là en 1975 vous êtes
en vacances à belle-ile-en-mer avec
votre famille c'est vrai ça et jacques
75 kg panossian jacques weber passe
jacques weber parce j'avais b retour
d'un fils voilà il vous vous voyez vous
dit on a besoin d'une figurante qui
passent dans la caméra avec un chat dans
les bras
un espace a fait cela il est là est en
train de tourner un film et on se rend
compte et je lui dis que je vais tourner
1,4 et il me dit enfin immédiate
comédienne parce que vu le physique vu
ce que je ressens vous devriez s'il vous
diriger vers cette profession
évidemment je vais être un arcade je
veux défendre mais voilà votre côté un
peu à social comme j'ai dit vous avez
fait peut-être une bonne avocate aussi
oui parce que dans mon idée des travaux
4 c'était évidemment l'avocat de la
défense
et c'était pour essayer de défendre les
personnages qui étaient mal juger ou mal
aimé et en fait je me suis rendu compte
que que ça s'est poursuivi dans la façon
dont je choisis les peyrolais c'est que
je sois nature des rôles de personnages
non aimable départ et je veux qu'on
finisse par aisée mais parce qu'on les
aura compris ou pas ce que je mange
d'avocats oui voilà c'est que c'est
comme dans top gun round au début il est
le début n'est pas sympa et après il y
aurait il tout le monde l'est beaucoup
moins
alors vous allez donc vos plantes est
allé au cours florent
oui comme florent votre premier film
j'ai l'hôtel de la plage de michelle
lang en 81 en fait dans la peau d'un
flic avec delon vous avez dit en parlant
de l'ange et est totalement sous son
influence
alors comme vous avez fait la publicité
bullet excusez moi ça cgt totalement son
influence j'étais comme une armoire vide
dont j'ai laissé remplir les étagères de
choses qui n'étaient pas à moi et la fin
du deuxième but j'ai tout vide et j'ai
commencé à remplir avec mes affaires je
pense que quand on vit des choses
importantes riche intense ça remplit une
armoire forcément et c'est vrai que
quand on a 20 ans
à part si on a vécu
une enfance à la zola ou quelque chose
très difficile
à 20 ans on a quand même beaucoup moins
de choses à partager et à dire et a
exprimé et que certaines rencontres et
certaines choses vécues vous permettre
de raz de marée de remplir plus
rapidement ses étagères et c'est vrai
que la rencontre avec alain delon et
vidéos par mois vous avez des choses à
vous dans l'armoire ou non
gj conservé beaucoup de choses mais j'ai
mieux c'est des choses qui
m'appartiennent où j'ai osé mettre des
choses qui m'appartiennent ce que
différents aussi parce que je pense que
quand on est plus jeune
on a souvent on accepte des kim a lyon
on accepte des gens qui vont vous guider
par ce qu'on n'a pas confiance en soi
parce qu'on a peur parce que moi je suis
pas quelqu'un qui explique la confiance
donc c'est vrai que j'ai eu tendance à
écouter des personnages plus mature que
moi et ça m'a en grandissant j'ai
découvert des choses qui m'appartenaient
pas et donc j'essaie de les garer que
vous devez garder beaucoup de choses de
dole on vous dit pas quand même à ne pas
rio afin wenta rio a soif vous dites pas
ça aime paris envie de prendre l'avion
non non non 86 besson 90 nikita le vrai
point de départ de ma carrière vous dit
et c'est vrai que dans ce film vous
étiez exceptionnel vous avez vu ça oui
bon super bonne
avec la lettonie on a eu le césar de
meilleure actrice magnifique aux états
unis d'amérique et moi j'ai vu la
version américaine et code nina c'est ça
qui est une vrai daube quoi tu peux me
permets que vous pouvez en faire un
remake de code avec messi messi il
s'appelle code nina et c'est le rythme
mais j'ai pas dis cela parce qu'ils sont
évidemment très à l'aise qu'on soit
super mal à l'aise si vous pouviez faire
un peu les manèges je sais que je vais
pas d'armoire j'ai une penderie non mais
rassurez vous on est on est on est
justement je suis fasciné par les gens
conscience de la répartie qui ont faim
qui ont ce que vous avez quoi votre
talent côtoyons nikita nous indique est
en même temps le tout dans la poubelle
et tous n'auraient pas pu - je sais quoi
c'est quand elles sont quand ben quand
on saute dans la cuisine ce cas se fait
tirer parce qu'il est bon dit qu'il a
poursuivi sa route alors que deux
secondes pour passer de de la cuisine
away au vide ordures soit mais si à ce
moment là elle passe trouver qui à
domicile qu arrive pendant japonais
ils visent ils veulent la peau ni visé
tout à l'heure un bail
je prends livres de seconde attaque a
thought 4 d'ordures a surtout dans la
poubelle
elle va juste à roppe hop elle va devoir
il s'attend à ce qu'à tout ça pour un
poussin
[Applaudissements]
tout ça quand guillaume minutes oui
c'est fort bien alors pour conclure
cette interview il ya une phrase de vous
j'espère que je vais la restituer comme
il faut parce que tu es assez étonnante
vous dites mon rêve au fond c'était
peut-être pas d'être comédienne serait
plutôt peut-être été d'avoir une vie
toute simple de femme au foyer qui
élèverait ses enfants et dont le montre
de marie rentrerait tous les soirs mais
ça n'a pas été mon destin vous pensez ça
sérieusement vous avez dit que vous
aviez un coût d'un coup de déprime je
pense qu'on ne maîtrise pas sa vie donc
saisir tout un tout un problème de
philosophie quoi ya ceux qui pensent
qu'ils sont maîtres de leur vie puis il
ya ceux qui pensent qu'ils sont services
de l' envie de partage la théorie que
nos services de sa vie c'était dès que
vous avez le regrette pas avoir été une
femme au foyer avec un mari qui rentrent
le soir et qui dit comme disait du qui
ni l'autre jour la bûche ériger une
bûche dans la cheminée
oui d'avoir une vie fait c'est quoi une
vie c'est parce que c'est même pas une
vie c'est un état d'esprit
la façon dont est constituée la façon
dont on les construit j'aurais peut-être
préféré que ce soit plus simple bien
vous êtes prêts pour une interview
la bnda c'est quoi
vous allez voir bougeait pas
[Applaudissements]
je vais un peu bougé en position s'est
rendu compte
vous le serez pour la prochaine phase
alors là dans cette lumière à vos yeux
c'est le jeu looking tout va très bien
je vais regarder la à ces jeux donc
jeune homme les yeux là on n'a pas non à
un film de cul la gentillesse qu'on peut
brancher la bonne chaîne enfin
franchement serge de cuir neuf mois qui
vient non pas l'interview ten dam c'est
simple c'est le plus le moins quoi c'est
la ville et des hauts des bas
voilà mais je vous vois si je sais pas
répond je réponds pas ben ouais pour né
pas il ya la banderole vous allez vous
dites car les oliviers quand vous savez
par là vous êtes joker voyait pas de
problème un problème alors qu'est ce que
vous préférez en vo non ça va trop vite
elle dit n'importe quoi qui tu as en
foot qu'est ce que j'y vais niger en
fait ce que j'ai critiqué tout à l'heure
c'est à dire en fait
mon cerveau bon vous trouvez vous êtes
trop cérébral oui mais c'est à la fois
ce que j'aime c'est tout le contraire de
l'undr trop facile c'est ce que vous
préférez en vous ce que vous détestez en
vous c'est la même chose c'est des
langues le cerveau ou à la fin vous
l'adorez vous le détestez aulas mouais
ça c'est des questions à c'était vrai
question add on n'est pas couché on va
faire plus simple est ce que vous
préférez dans le cinéma
il ya plein de choses et projecteurs
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça c'est
l'émotion que safran culture de tournai
ou de se voir après à n'en savoir si les
bases non c'est une fréquence page et
torture ses démos trop fort mais c'est
je vais même pas parce que vous détestez
dans le cinéma mais fausse valeur sinon
bien alors on va terminer ce que vous
avez de plus sexy en vous mon cerveau
peut-être que c'est bon oui c'est énorme
ça tient une place énorme tendance est
le plus embêtant le plus intéressant est
peut-être le plus c'est que ce n'est pas
être simple excusez moi comme grossesse
je vais aborder je trouve très jolie
mais vous devez pas être simple comme
filles 1 il ya des jours un an à mon
amant je suis bon je savais pas c'est
peut-être pas une fille bien merci
[Applaudissements]
oui et non mais quand tu cerveau je n'ai
pas intelligent saint vous vous posez
des questions nous torturer un peu les
méninges comment dire ouais posséder une
intelligence et profitez de la vie
attendez vous êtes jolie vous fait des
bons films
est-ce que ça va non bien alors
j'accueille maintenant en homme
politique
ah ouais et alors c'est assez
exceptionnel parce que c'est dans cette
émission reçoit toutes les semaines on
sera toutes les semaines qu'il ya des
émissions en soit des hommes politiques
et alors c'est plus en plus dure parce
qu'ils sont tous mis en examen et alors
on a trouvé un bon vous cherchez la
seconde vague n'était pas mis en examen
dont qu'il peut venir ici s'appelle jean
luc mélenchon
à
j'arrivais n'engendrant soir anne
parillaud dans le cas des oliviers linda
hardy jean luc mélenchon vous vous êtes
vais pas vous n'avez pas de problème
vous de quel point de vue du point de
vue judiciaire je dirais attend le bon
star il vous dira tout est clair il n'y
a plus moyen de trouver dans paris un
costard croisés pour les hommes de mon
âge donc la mode est aux costards
balladur vous avez tous les airs d'un
berlingo dès que vous le faire mais il
faut être creux comme quelqu'un qui a 25
ans qui voit là je pense que je fais ce
que je veux c'est pareil les couleurs
non non non je veux dans la couleur
allait bien je vous demande de vous
arrêter tout de suite bien jean-luc
mélenchon c'est comme ça que c'est une
prétendante à la dure salut c'est
marrant balladur il fait flipper tout le
monde tu fais balladur tout le monde est
là bien jean-luc que vous êtes sénateur
de l'essonne
mais sérieuses et pas pour un sénateur
c'est plutôt chez pas mal les sénateurs
j'imagine toujours des mecs comme ça un
sénateur et un des plus jeunes sénateurs
de deux français en 86 oui oui parce que
jusqu'à 74
il fallait avoir 40 ans pour être élu et
alors ça a changé c'est passé à 35
passagers un élu
j'ai été élu pile poil 35 ans à moi vous
avez 35 ans il est où là j'en ai 46
avant j'ai flippé en moi j'ai 35 ans si
je ressemble à ça mais je dirai jamais
non plus alors tout va bien on dit il
alors bon vous avez éteint on va parler
un petit peu de votre votre carrière
politique il faut dire quand même
c'était le premier en 91 a initié un
projet qui devenu le pacs après oui
c'était le cul qu'à l'époque
non moi ça s'appelait nuque me pose tout
moi j'ai appelé ça le partenariat civil
vous voulez mais que les frères soit
possible pour tout le monde ce n'est pas
simplement un mariage homosexuel comme
l'a été le pacs a apprécié les
homosexuels qui m'ont donné l'idée parce
qu'on m'avait envoyé en 88 c'est la
seule idée qui vous ont donné au moins
vous attendez vous allez voir passer du
moment un peu comme ça donc on invite à
1,88 à une soirée ces gais pour les
libertés on me voit là pour faire la
campagne de mitterrand
donc on m'avait dit parler des nouveaux
modes de vie alors je commence la vie
les jeunes tout ça je parle parle pas
trop mal et quand j'ai fini bon les gens
qui étaient là me disent vraiment ce que
vous dites c'est bien mais vous savez
c'est pas notre problème et il me
raconte ce qui se passe moi je n'avais
pas la moindre idée de ce à quoi je
savais pas qu'il y avait ça il y avait
cette cruauté
quand il y en a un des deux qui meurent
qui j'étais dehors bref donc je me suis
dit j'ai oublié accord
j'ai oublié mais maintenant on est
capable de faire des choses
[Applaudissements]
natoire la gaule inquiète pas mis en
examen qui fait des trucs d'ailleurs
bien alors là vous exagérez écouter fait
pas ça fait pas croire qu'on sait c'est
pas bien c'est un plat attendez vous
voulez pourquoi je voulais que j'ai
continué vous savez bien du tout je vais
lui dire deux anneries convoqué on avait
invité julien dray il mal tenebaye il
est pas bien c'est vrai que c'est bien
car derrière cette histoire de montres
la êtes au courant
bah oui j'ai lu ça dans les espaces et
alors non j'ai pas et on lui reproche
d'avoir acheté une montre de 150000
balle va devoir payer la moitié en
liquide oui je suis alors évidement
milian liquide
ah oui du gaz liquide il est noyé moi je
crois que c'est plutôt non moi je suis
comme vous je trouve ça fou il achète un
avion le mentor de festivent autres
qu'on est un petit peu en dehors de ça
il faut être un petit peu un moment
donné faut être sérieux dans un débat je
comprends tout à fait ce que ce que dit
moi ce que je connais de lui
c'est la passion par l'engagement un
type qui passe sa vie à sa caisse ou je
vous répond mathieu l'histoire de
moutons alors je m'en fous bon c'est
vrai par êtes vous merci pour les sous
titres c'est une émission bien tenu
dites moi donc j'ai commencé comme prof
de français en 74 est entré à l'unef en
77 au au ps vous appréciez beaucoup donc
là l'organisation et la méthode de joxe
et avant vous êtes et trotskistes avant
mais vous avez déclaré je ne pouvais pas
être communiste avait bradé la
révolution dont vous étiez trotskiste
vous étiez donc au pci c'est ça oui moi
j'étais trop de qui je veux dire ça me
fait plaisir vous me le disait parce que
ça fait maintenant un mois deux mois que
ça dure
on a pris comme ça toc toc un ou deux
visages de trotskistes
oui on transforme notre histoire notre
jeunesse en une histoire terrible d'un
complot une secte oui moi je suis fier
de ce que j'ai fait d'accord j'en ai un
magnifique souvenir
vous savez bien jean-luc mélenchon que
ça c'est pas peu dire c'est une position
dans votre jeunesse revêtait trotskisme
d'autres ont été communiste d'autres
mais ce qu'on reproche aux 6 sélections
paie les lambertistes c'est à dire 7 ces
gens qui sont autour de pierre boussel
alias lambert et qui ont infiltré un
petit peu tous les rouages de la
république
l'une a écouté mais c'est du cinéma tout
ça et à chaque génération
vous avez j'ai pas peur des mots une
élite humaine les gens ne s'engagent bon
dans les années 60 c'était ceux qui
refusaient la guerre d'algérie ce
qu'était pas communistes étaient tous ps
eut donc un prêt à vous y retrouver des
pssu partout bon dans les années 70 et
début 80 bas tout le monde était extrême
gauche
c'est normal dans dans notre génération
donc ces gens là c'est après il ya des
réseaux et vous en trouver partout
écouter des rezzous xoom fait rigoler on
se connaît où on se connaît pas on a
passé commence une affaire générationnel
si c'est si formidable d'avoir été à
l'eau c'est pourquoi je ce pas un peu
pas reconnaître qu'il a été lui
peut-être parce qu'il n'y a pas été ou
êtes pas pour une question légale et des
gens qui a quand même des gens qui l'ont
aidé témoigne un ennemi terrible j'étais
je n'ai pas vu vous n'allez jamais gagné
ce que tout le monde témoigne ans il ya
plein de gens qui ont témoigné en disant
jospin il était responsable d'une
dynamique ce qui était une structure de
base dans le système trotskiste et s'il
avait même un surnom un pseudo qui était
mon dieu blad c'était michel et il ya
des gens qui l'ont vu payer ses
cotisations mais qu'il me dise moi
j'étais pas été inventée non mais moi
j'étais j'étais responsable dans mon
coin j'ai rien vu de tout ça je jeu ça
m'amuse toujours un peu parce que ça ça
participe c'est plus d'ambiance
fantasmagorique
tout d'un coup il ya un tas de gens qu
israël qu on envie de dire quelque chose
ça tombe bien deux ans avant les
présidentielles on joint l'utile à
l'agréable maintenant laissons pas que
ça soit négatif pour jospin d'avoir été
trop timide je vais pas dire si négatif
ça prouve qu'il a on peut leur souvent
lui reproche d'avoir pris strauss kahn
comme ministre des finances et des
trains p d'être un peu trop à droite
je trouve pas que ce soit négatif pour
lui le fait d'avoir été trotskiste ça
prouve son attachement sera bien au
socialisme ça serait bien comme ça je me
sentirai mieux entourer ok j'ose pas on
passe au chapitre suivant en 88 donc
déçus par la politique de rocard un peu
centriste vous fonder la nouvelle école
socialiste qu'est devenue la gauche
socialiste en 91 avec vous n'aurez pas
des mois vous marrer avec marie thérèse
lienemann j'y viendrai nom marie noëlle
pas marie thérèse mal c'est celle qui
sucre des fraises je viendrai jean
christophe cambadélis dans la plus pure
et dure qu'un mois jusqu'en bas des
listes non plus n'était pas là n'étaient
pas là quand même jamais kamba il fait
ses trucs
imaginons qu'elle soit déjà à sa cure de
faire ce qu'on a à faire on peut pas
quand enfin il était numéro 2 du psg
jette au ps oui oui je les numéros 2 oui
oui mais c'est un type bien
cambadélis oui bon il travaillait vous
savez bien pour un dénommé yves lainé
qui était un ancien et psn non seulement
ils avaient un emploi fictif
en plus c'était pour à m'inquiéter du fn
par le racing c'est curieux cette
affaire
mais c'est marrant c'est comme philippe
sollers quand j'ai dit vous avez été mal
oui je dis ouais ouais ouais c'est vrai
c'est pas bien enfin donc vraiment envie
quand quand on fait une connerie on peut
pas dire oui vous avez raison c'est pas
bien mais attendez c'est pas moi qui ai
fait la connerie n'a fait qu'un mort des
listes avait fait partie d'un parti dont
il est le numéro de combat là je suis
comme vous je veux le journal je regarde
moi je connais un cambadélis dans le
journal j'en vois un autre
moi je connais un autre cambadélis
connaît un organisateur je connais un
orateur je connais un homme politique
engagé jusqu'au fond des tripes ce
nouveau journal voit autre chose
je suis comme vous je me dis vers moi je
comprends à 100 c'est parce que non
seulement alors j'attends et là bon il
dans un mauvais moment ce n'est
peut-être pas le moment pour moi de me
présenter
ouais je vais attendre un petit peu la
bête c'est quoi cette histoire
ah oui bien sûr parce que là il va être
condamné
j'en sais rien on va mieux avoir enfin
je sais pas moi je trouve que quand on a
un emploi fictif déjà c'est pas terrible
qui était au sac le vivent l'aîné il
était aussi bien comme ça mais oui j'ai
lu tout ça commence à pas trop la télé
c'est marrant ça fait c'est à ça fera
écouter paltrow parce que vous la
regardez pas sourcée ses soucis ça
j'aime mieux vous dire qu il se dit ouh
là là où on voit déjà beaucoup trop quoi
pas croire on rigole pas tous les jours
mon dernière question qui est prêt je
vous vous occupez de monsieur après visa
parce que pour l'instant l'homme et fait
parler les autres vous de 95 98 était
secrétaire de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées vous avez des infos particulière
sur la vente des frégates françaises à
taïwan
c'est dire que c'est sûr que non et
c'est pas grave non j'en ai pas je suis
pas trop pour que l'on donne du matériel
à taiwan s'y loue pour l'interroger où
l'homme politique
non je vais vous laisser entre les mains
de linda hardy on va être un élu mais on
ne bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà avait dit linda je vous ai appelé
jean loup vous pressez vous préférez que
je vous appelle jean luc hommes et 7
sénateurs
je crois que vous pouvez m'appeler comme
vous voulez alors jean luc je vous
appelle aujourd'hui jean-luc vous avez
un compte
en combinant un concubinage c'est ça
avec votre compagne pascale aujourd'hui
à choisir vous opteriez plutôt pour le
pacs pour le mariage bah c'est à elle
qu'il faut poser la question soit celle
qui porte la culotte
vous l'avez déjà demandé sa main bah
ouais ça n'attendent pas savons banon et
c'est pas c'est pas son truc
vous vous si vous suivez c'est vous
qu'êtes vous êtes top gun dans la tête
pour essayer de lui voler sa vous tous
si c'est après que ice man il
mais je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
est ce que vous croyez qu'on a mûri n'a
toujours un qui s'emmerdent et un
caisson ya quoi elle a toujours un qui
s'emmerdent est un qui sauf rhône pour
tous chez vous c'est le cas qu'ils
s'emmerdent être calqué sur blogeee
consommateurs
sans blague alors le défi différent on
vit avec d'autres mecs compliment qu'on
pût main à toute la famille l'avenant
vous pensez pas non je me reconnais pas
là-dedans mais moins rouge et 47 ans
donc à votre avis pour quelle raison un
homme pourra-t-il prendre une maîtresse
je suis ronde et bonne raison pour le
sexe pour le sexe
j'en sais rien c'est monsieur qui le dit
mme alors c'est que vous pensez que le
sacré plus relevé un remariage plus les
relever sexuels les plus retors mariage
mais qu'est-ce que vous êtes tout de
suite séduit chez elles ou en l iap à
rio qui se dit c'est le tour de belles
manches en a c'est
il faut pas se planter
effectivement depuis pas c'est son
regard ses yeux noirs sa moustache
son regard captivant ce n'est pas lui
c'est soir quand vous allez rentrer
quelle est la première chose que vous
allez lui dire ouf
[Applaudissements]
alors maintenant à faire une petite
pause on va regarder l'extrait d'une
caissette qui est en vente libre dans le
commerce ça s'appelle les yeux dans la
fesse et c'est bien évidemment jean yves
lafesse magnéto conceptuellement aux
brillants de france
c'est vrai qu'il nous regarde
actuellement en braille
vous me demandez ce que vous arrivez là
je comprends pas c'est comment voyez
vous regarde maintenant oui je dis en
braille
le problème c'est que vous pouvez pas
vous moquer comme ça puis non j'espère
c'est que ces petites bêtises
jean françois et bien voici donc de
reprendre très rapidement donc cette
semaine est consacrée aux aveugles
c'est nous voyons une regarde en braille
est à poil
le battre à pellin le ghana tout les
dégâts directs one piece et sur les
peurs amant n'ai pas vu un gars l'une
est un grand et des souks où on s'est
mis de côté allez allez allez
elle est en train de pisser sur les
peurs depuis ce matin serait 4
c'est devenir la mode et puis sur les
flancs il y avait un prête nom
ça n'arrête pas son mach veux pas me
rend peut-être pas gentil
elle gentil parce que
non mais franchement est gentil poli
peur maintenant je les appelle les yeux
devant la presse
tiens mélenchon si vous avez l'air de
bien beau marais voilà agile avec saab
ont maintenant j'accueille quelqu'un que
vous connaissez tous et vous appréciez
tous a depuis très longtemps
c'est sur ses neveux du vieux bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir vidéo
[Applaudissements]
les accueillir merci beaucoup a pas que
je suis céline balitran monsieur kim
darby oui mais si on s'occupe de
recycler des mannequins l'ascension
sociale belinda s'en sort très bien
d'ailleurs on se félicite pour le même
qu'à répéter
vous devriez vue voix off et de la
réinsertion sociale nous c'est bien
alors là je monte le livre de frédéric
mitterrand dont ça s'appelle mémoires
d'exil voilà voilà voilà
alors c'est août est aussi six épisodes
sur france 2 l'été dernier le premier
épisode commence où c'est terminé les
aigles foudroyés
donc ça commence par le massacre des
romanov parler des suites la fuite de
ceux qui ont échappé en soit on peut
appeler ça un livre d'histoire mais avec
un s histoire est un peu romanesque mais
histoire quand même alors donc ça c'est
la fin de tout ces gens là les romanov
les habsbourgs grill et renzo laisse des
trous c'est tous les jours qu'elle roule
dans top gun
pittman offs et les russes les
habsbourgs c'est l'autrichien one the
air c'est évidemment à la partie
variable iron salerne pas terrible bah
oui alors il a mal familles n'ont pas
tous mais après la guerre de la lah pour
pour sauver la touriste ouailles à bhl
toutes ces perruches en plus mais non
allez allez ah oui j'ai pas pu mener
n'avait pas pensé à mon sens assez mais
c'est très bien tout le monde en parle
c'est un peu comme un dîner en ville ce
soit d'un seul coup la maîtresse de
maison c'est à dire moi je me rends
compte qu'on a mis qu'on a mis en face
melançon évitant un long que c'est votre
côté
c'est par habitant plus beaucoup pas non
vous l'aimez bien fait partie de ceux
est ce que vous faites partie de ceux
qui aimait beaucoup françois mitterrand
tant qu'il a été président c'est à dire
pendant 14 ans et qui maintenant on
arrête pas de taper sur lui parce que
moi je suis fasciné de voir c'est comme
si françois mitterrand avait commis tous
les crimes du siècle titanic presse que
c'est lui enfin je veux dire ça n'aurait
pas terminé son petit anniversaire c'est
peut-être lui d'accord on avancera
ordinaire non seulement je ne je ne
jouais pas prêt pas sur l'image
mais je pense que si la plupart des gens
mais un petit peu de courage dans les
dîners en ville comme il dit j'ai
remarqué une chose est toujours une
quelconque qu'acteur qui commence la
gnagna rebond s'il y en a un qui résiste
et qui m'a dit moi passa devant moi
parce qu'il est mort aussitôt vous en
avez de 3 qui disent et moi je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est une petite
affaire de courage vous avez assez
raison manière faut pas se laisser faire
il les sait très bien l'amour parce que
je pense que il ya une haine qui lui
colle à la peau qui a commencé le 1er
jour où figure quand même
il était dur avec
avec les gens qu'il approchait et il il
avait à tout un jeu de séduction qui
faisait que on savait jamais donc quand
on entre dans son bureau s'il allait
être exquis charmant ou trés trés
castrateur quand son regard se poser sur
vous et qu'il était de mauvaise humeur
c'était la chose la plus glaçante que
moi j'ai jamais vu plus impressionné
vous m'impressionnez la même alors vous
dites que tout le monde la nostalgie des
grandes familles en fête des grandes
destinées de la preuve regardez met en
scène en chair stéphanie s'il aimerait
bien parce qu'elle est quand même un
côté camping alors les historiens des
fois mettre un petit peu en cause votre
book à vos besoins généralement ce sont
des savoirs plaisir à jean luc mélenchon
va donner pendant 60 ans pas les
fameuses histoires et en question
pendant 60 ans ils ont amusé ont
présenté la révolution communiste comme
un événement extraordinaire
alors que lénine à restaurer la peine de
mort pour les enfants de 12 ans c'est
vrai c'est vrai mais je sais pas faire
faire quand même sur celle des
trotskistes oui mais moi ce que je fais
c'est ce que j'essaye j'essaye de
historiquement d'être très très exact et
deux en fait c'est rêve je veux pas
vendre mon truc mais c'est très juste
d'ailleurs sur les dates sur les trucs
quand même à venir dans les jambes ou
chez dans la manière dont ça se passait
sur le climat économique et c'est à
partir de ce moment là on peut essayer
de retrouver un peu l'esprit romanesque
et je dis pas ce sont des livres
d'histoire cd l'histoire romanesque
mais s'il ya est ce que cette animation
on est très famille unie cette nostalgie
dans un pathos oui mais pas à nous et
nostalgie des femmes unies s'est pas dû
au divorce de vos parents c'est un peu
difficile de parler de ça mais c'est
vrai que je pense que toute sa vie toute
sa vie on poursuit van poursuite des des
rêves d'enfance et donc on parle de soi
aussi moi je parle de moi danser et ça
je suis je me prends pour les banques et
ça s'entend mais étant enfant dont il y
avait effectivement ce problème mais le
bilan global à 2 c sur et puis avait
aussi ce désir d'être célèbre parce que
quand vous avez fait votre fils il ya
une chose souci puisqu'on parlait
françois mitterrand tout à l'air et
c'était une chose dont je parle jamais
mais comme on est entre nous afin de
battre je suis là je vivais caméra fait
ce qu'on parle de ça plus qu'on parle de
ça il y avait aussi une chose quand même
qui était très impressionnante depuis
l'enfance c'était la présence de
françois mitterrand quand même qu'ils
peser très fortement ou ne se dit pas
tout ça en mano contrastée on peut être
que fier de ça mais c'était quelque
chose quand même de très très
impressionnant dès qu'on était enfant et
moi je vous ai plutôt partie de là de la
partie bourgeoise la famille dire lycée
janson avenue victor hugo
sports d'hiver enfin tout ça et françois
mitterrand était déjà
quelqu'un qui est et qui était très à
gauche qui avait quitté le gouvernement
à plusieurs reprises sous la quatrième
république parce qu'il n'était pas
d'accord avec une politique une dérive
de droite etc
et c'était c'était une chose très
impressionnante quand vous êtes un
enfant que vous intéressé quand même un
petit peu à ce qui se passe d'avoir
cette image très forte voire vous
appelez le neveu du communiste avec cole
voilà le nouveau duc la ministre il
était assez partagés parce que vous
aimiez bien de gaulle vous avez dit ils
vont se battre jusqu'à vous évidemment
parlant déroulé mitterrand ils vont se
battre jusqu'à la mort la mienne mais
c'est vrai et c'est vrai qu'un jour
alors que vous aviez fait votre film
avec michel morvan et bourvil votre
surnom s'était enfin votre nom d'acteur
c'était frédéric robert oui parce que
j'avais pas m mitterrand et un jour le
11 novembre 1960 voulait aller saluer le
général de gaulle et le surnom qui
choisit à ce moment là ses fennecs
françois carambolage j'étais en face de
de gaulle et je me suis dit mais si mon
oncle me voyez ça serait atroce et donc
les petits et la psychologie
l'inconscient a fait que le nom que je
lui ai donné j'ai donné ces français
j'étais là-bas dans la fille de suite et
glissez parce que je préférerais que
l'on soit proche possible ira finalement
il serrait la main à la vieille dame
tout le monde était décoré de tapis avec
moi il a dû me prendre pour le fils d'un
résistant héroïque
il m'a serré la main et tout va se
présenter mais frédéric françois s'est
passé comme ça mettra alors étudiant
votre votre vie pour préparer cette
interview j'ai trouvé que vous aviez
fait science infuse lna et vous étiez
destiné à l'inspection des finances
heureusement fait remonter des cinémas
vous avez perdu 3 millions c'est suite à
vos ennuis d'argent avec les cinémas
olympique à l'époque où on s'est connus
et j'étais très longtemps et on se dit
obligé de faire de la télévision elle a
une phrase formidable de frédéric
mitterrand quand il joue on lui demande
comment c'est et quand vous êtes arrivé
à la télévision il dit quand on a passé
son enfance et son adolescence dans un
milieu où on ne parle pas d'argent à
table et ou dans le métro en fait sa une
place vieille dame
on est terriblement handicapé quand on
arrivé là
sauf que c'est définitif c'est vrai
j'aimerais savoir un truc est ce que
pour autant se montrer la télévision si
vous avez été pistonné non non là où ça
c'est génial
ils ont cru ça allait faire plaisir à
mon oncle c'est génial alors que si lui
il avait su il aurait immédiatement dit
il n'est pas question qu'ils rentrent à
la télévision mais ça s'est passé comme
ça puis après j'en ai profité pour
regarder un petit magnéto maintenant
alors là c'est parce que ce soir de
l'union ont beau jeune homme oui enfin
vous le voyez ce que je veux parler non
mais vous allez voir pire manitou ch
bonsoir bonsoir de bordeaux j'ai perdu
mon diadème excusez moi je suis tu je
sors donc dans cette tenue légèrement
affriolantes car je voulais rendre
hommage à la ville de bordeaux rendre
hommage à la ville de bordeaux dans une
barrique parce que le vin est au coeur
de la ville de bordeaux rendre hommage à
la ville de bordeaux en tenue de
ballerines parce que le grand théâtre
est au coeur du coeur de bordeaux l'un
des plus beaux monuments des villes
françaises mais puisque nous sommes au
grand théâtre
et puisque j'ai mis donc ses atours pour
honorer l'architecte victor louis
honorons aussi le compositeur qui fut le
plus joué dans ce théâtre lors de son
inauguration jeu honorons gluck avec
l'une des plus belles voix du monde la
voix de teresa cerise gala qui va nous
chanter j'ai perdu mon eurydice
[Applaudissements]
je veux montrer parce que je savais que
j'allais olivier ce cas là vous voulez
montrer donc que finalement vous êtes un
des premiers à vous habiller en fille
s'était confiée quand même et c'est une
très grosse erreur directe en plus c'est
très bien que c'était totalement direct
oui oui c'était assez amusant ça comme
ça vous allez avoir droit à un ordi view
lumière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un regard compris n'ont pas bougé par la
lumière s'éteint d'accord on fait mine
mais j'ai pas beaucoup bougé dernière
chose que vous faites avant de vous
coucher
la dernière chose que je fais avant de
me coucher
c'est à aucun intérêt je me lave les
dents avant c'est tout oui c'est pas la
question et du j'enlève mon préservatif
ou non non non je n'ai pas l'occasion de
m'en servir beaucoup
bon c'est quoi la sauce vous faites
avant de vous coucher moi je me paye
mieux et oui c'est un peu ça reste un
peu tu me touches pas
to be
mais ç'a eu les bras si on la jette au
froid dans la glace quand vous voyez
vous dites quoi
oui bonsoir monsieur m'a dit bonsoir
près ce qui nous énerve le plus en vous
la chose qui vous énerve le coup de
supporter pas chez vous c'est quoi la
faiblesse est chez moi ce qui vous
énerve le plus chez moi que vous fassiez
des progrès chez linda ce que vous aimez
un rien je mens
rien ne m'énerve c'est un menteur si
vous êtes déjà est inaccessible c'est ça
qui est énervant mélenchon qui vient
d'être enlevé les primaires seraient
seulement les prudes affaire soit
peut-être une version gt
mais l'accord petit bleu c'est sûr que
c'est le reste j'ai pas de voiture j'ai
pas de terminer cette brève du cac et
mélenchon c'est mieux que naisse c'est
bien comme surnom pour vous éclater la
soudure semble un peu on plaît et si
vous restez 24 heures avis vous feriez
quoi si rester 24 heures à vivre
s'il me restait 24 heures à vivre
c'est long oui oui mais voilà je pense
que c'est ça que je ferai il hésiterait
je citerai pas répondu et ouais c'est ça
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
qui a été réalisé par notre patricia
gagne au ces qui effectivement est allé
demander aux gens s'ils accepteraient le
pire cadeau de noël magnéto le pire
cadeau de noël qu'on pourrait vous faire
alors ça serait une nuit avec kad et
olivier commentée par frédéric
mitterrand ça serait assez d'eads a
redit son agglo des radis qui chantent
noël nu avec kad et olivier à 0 ring ça
c'est horrible d'être mitterrand et on
avait un minuit avec kad et olivier de
commenter par frédéric mitterrand
l'avait baptême du tout en faire c'est
le deuxième quoi c'est a redit son
innocence noël sa vie avec vous savez
avec les trucs du moyen-âge là où on est
on est saisi on est tenu au poignet puis
à la tête puis un gros casque et voilà
un duo ardisson a redit sur cd qui
chantent noël
ouais parce qu'en même temps comme
cadeau je pourrais l'estimé que c'est le
pire mais en même temps ça peut devenir
collector moi c'est kad et olivier
commenté par frédéric mitterrand que
j'aime beaucoup par ailleurs mais là
franchement ce serait terrible nuit avec
kad et olivier merci a commenté sur la
garde non ça je veux pas merci je
préfère une yeux et frédéric mitterrand
commentée par kad et olivier
leonard et chante moi non merci soyez
gentils fait pas ça fait pas ça ou alors
avec moi
mystérieux donc c'est filmé à disneyland
endroits où la vente par an continue
jusqu'au 9 janvier
oui bien sûr c'est pas gad si l'on
regarde le nombril d'oubli verluca
nombril c'est pas terrible on ne fait
pas un score formidable on n'est pas
cadeau de noël quoi non on est pas qu
elle bien alors maintenant l'émission
rentrer dans une succession de trois
invités qui ont en commun c'est normal
c'est la période de noël qui commence
ils ont en commun d'avoir rencontré dieu
d'une façon ou d'une autre le ce soit
oui mais il ressent puisque c'est
pendant 14 ans oui absolument
donc nous allons recevoir successivement
mal en charge et michel delpech et
fabrice tiozzo 1er 3 à leur façon ont
rencontré dieu est en transe par
mallaury nataf
vous connaissez jean luc mélenchon sur
le champ ses rangs les sénateurs je
connais madame naf naf naf monsieur
roblochon à chanter ça va être cod c'est
eh bien c'est sympa de l'affiché comme
sadate honnête
ouais c'est bien ouais ouais ouais ouais
surtout nos amis les spectateurs le
sachet la fiche de thierry et céline
comment ça va s'élever combien ça fait
combien oui bah autant qui n'a pas
autant kinder et vous malgré je suis
perdu ma dans ses courses et des rations
je sais pas c d e gzp n'ont pas toutes
la gorge
oui mais je les âges y regarde pas les
étiquettes je les prends comme ça j'ai
mes tubes on saluera du haschich
si bien que chez ces deux mois pour les
trois quarts de la télévision ménard est
en train de me dire on dirait qu'elle
était bien une petite bourde des locaux
c'est n'importe quoi je donne parce
qu'il peut pas alors du coup ça chauffe
eau paris où la mairie en a reçus ici
hélène rollès c'est quand je dis rôle
elle me casse et jacky jacut bobbitt non
j'ai vu à la télévision jeudi comme ça à
la fin j'ai dit bah écoutez maintenant
on va appeler tous les gens de chez ab
et j'ai dit
mallaury nataf et deux jours après je
reçois ce disque de vous maintenant que
vous vous disais qu'on avait rencontré
dieu ben voilà c'est voilà je reçois ce
disque alors on va écouter un petit peu
comme ça voilà
oui
sow
musicalement c'est clair
m
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi mon préféré mon regret c'est
celui-là
[Musique]
il avait chanté donc on a reçu donc ce
disque qu'on a écouté et alors on a vu
effectivement technique adore la fête je
pas si vous connaissiez technique a
vraiment non mais s'était engagé dire
technikart et aux années 90 où vous
années 2000 ce que actuelle était aux
années 80 et face à vos années 70 comme
ça je vous le donne en franchement c'est
très engagé très bon j'ai une très bonne
équipe on a besoin de liberté
ils sont tous à moitié branleur est en
fait comme en produisent là des mines
qui n'aurait manqué non mais comme tout
bon 10 à 5 min ça y est c'est fini bien
normal auris était mallory 2 et quand on
s'est connu c'était mallory de zèle à
huer les grecs c'est au prix maintenant
il ya malo et rieux voilà et puis de
demain ça sera encore une chose ça peut
changer c'est évolutif c'est ça c'est au
juste me transforme donc moment se
transforme il ya peut-être d'autres
choses qui se transformeront je sais pas
encore je vais pas devenir un homme
quand même pourquoi pas des fois la vie
quotidienne au 20e siècle mais
maintenant je suis un homme je serai pas
sur moi
frédéric d'abord maintenant j'ai changé
je suis maman ça marche moins bien dans
son scénario si vous tout à l'heure vous
avez vous mal comme sur le site de cap
parce que j'ai peur quand même
bon alors j'ose à peine devenant en fait
c'est marie laurence donc c'est marrant
parce que vous étiez bon on peut dire
une starlette surmédiatisé de l'époque
pie ix supermarché gestion oui c'est ça
c'est toujours ça tu n'y as les abeilles
à 1
dans chez ab donc pour tf1 on connaît
vous évidemment c'est impérissable
épisode de la vague grâce à vous étiez
l'investigation c'est travailler dur et
un jour la commune photo enfin antoine a
regardé une cassette de tf1 programme
pour enfants le matin sont avertis et
envoyé mallaury nataf qui tournait comme
ça d'ailleurs on peut peut-être le voir
m
non nous on regarde tf1
d'accord on a publié la photo sha nous
apparaît qui se passe rien d'envoyer son
but à châtelaillon
c'est un choc que tu pas assez payés sur
tf1 non c'est pas ça c'est malheureux
mais jamais de culotte un sondage qui a
été fait sur europe la semaine dernière
il ya 65 % des femmes françaises qui ne
porte pas de culotte
on vient juste dans la moyenne un show
même combien 65% des eaux pourrait faire
un petit sondage
ce qu'on fait à son âge lever la main
celle qui porte la culotte
tu as triché pas un tricheur qui si on
les oblige à mettre des culottes service
public nous parlerons pas se permettre
ça va vous mettre un cierge un jour
peut-être bien le latic âgées le quota
nous on est obligé de mettre ses
culottes aux gens qui viennent vous avez
une culotte et vous verrez jamais jamais
service lit pas les garçons je sais de
ce type mais j'en ai jamais rien et donc
je suis content à millas pas devin mais
on est pareils on n'est pas n'importe
quoi oui alors oui tout à fait c'est 70%
des hommes mais des pans entiers
vient alors mallory donc quand vous
étiez adolescente vous avez commencé
alors est-ce que c'était une une école
de commerce que vous faisiez ou du droit
à sa dg sur les 2 avec deux magnifiques
à faire quand on a pas vraiment assez de
temps dans la journée dont je mens
rajouter encore plus comme ça j'étais
vous détruire et tuer père et mère pour
réussir cette époque là un matin je
voulais faire un casting pour ab quatre
jours après je tournais non mais
j'adorais vraiment ce métier c'est vrai
que je m'étais même posé la question que
moi je me fais des scénarios
complètement fou et je me dis si un jour
on me demande de choisir tes parents
crève et tu arrêtes ce métier bas
c'était clair les parents crevé je
continuais métier et avec le temps je me
suis dit peut-être comme je vais les
garder parce qu'on n'a pas une chance à
ben moi je peux pas j'ai décidé de les
garder donc arrêter le métier parce que
je sais ce que j'ai fait pendant que
alors en 93 dont vous faites le vous
commencez le fameux miel et les abeilles
et ça dure un an et demi le soir même
nous fait un peu ce théâtre rue
montorgueil pour parce que bon d'une
pièce
orange est bien content que ça
remplissait pas une vie quoi un cerveau
surtout presque une vie à la limite si
elle était très remplie 16 heures de
tournage par jour ça allait mais le
cerveau ça commence et je prie bon si je
continue comme ça quand j'aurai 60 ans
ça sera vraiment grave donc il valait 1
peut entraîner les neurones voilà donc
j'aime et j'ai fait un peu de théâtre et
moi je continue en faire maintenant
et alors ce que j'ai découvert en
préparant cette idée a vu c'est qu'à
l'époque vous étiez toujours défense est
en fait chez ab vous dit en fait à
l'époque chez ab on a pu mieux que
saviez pas ça chez ab on tue mais
constamment ses émissions pour la
jeunesse
mais pas un épisode où je ne sois pas
cassé c'est pour ça d'ailleurs convoi
j'aimais bien mon regard dans les salles
qui me faisait beau c'est parce qu'elle
n'admet particulier pendant un moment a
dit nemertes a des yeux bleus pour qu'on
les voit jamais je dernière j'ai inventé
une technique extraordinaire
j'ai un comédien la commedia là pour pas
que ça se voit je fais comme ça et je
regarde tous moyens et donc voilà ça
c'est un fumier des pétards chez ab s'il
fallait bien s'amuser c'est normal non
évocateur lire les textes de ses
chansons je les lisais pas en fait
c'était l'apprentissage mécanique je
m'isolais 3 4 minutes avant de tourner
je me concentrais que le joueur je t'ai
et cinq minutes après je me rappelais
plus on sait comment ça a été fait tout
ça est bon pour les beaucoup d'ecstasy
aussi beaucoup non olive ecstasy les
petites gens pour des ouvertures de
l'inconscient pourquoi non je comprends
que tout parce que ces trucs là je crois
qu'on va luchini adore s'était pointé
j'étais tous défoncés au point avec ça
et en fait c'est pour ça que ce sont de
grands de principe comme grand témoin
des grands sites comme et c'était
c'était une bouffée d'air frais quoi
c'est un peu surréaliste surtout qu'un
autre crs et j'étais carrément sauvage
wisekey et picabia tout ça il aurait été
très content je suis sûr qu'ils auraient
été encore vivant il aurait regardé j'en
suis persuadé
et alors en 95 donc le mia ne s'arrête
donc cliquer à biache match et là vous
faites un livre c'est vrai que ce livre
est assez étonnant c'est un livre
s'appelle à la vie à l'amour ou le
connaissez pas c'est à 166 ans
d'illustrations et de dans les photos de
ton pas que c'est préservatif
j'ai jamais compris celles en vue du
moment vous allez manger dit ah bah
tiens je mette ça il ya aussi wonder
woman
il ya des petites et des petites photos
de moi oui et donc il est bizarre ce
bouquin ans il est il est écrit comme ça
c'est cgt toutes mes photos depuis j'ai
tout jeté mes souvenirs et voilà j'ai un
livre c'est sympa alors en 95 vous posez
flandrien je sais je sais pas où c'est
écrit en fait on attend abc voyage et
président de tatouage tatouage c'est
malabar
mais non si vous voulez voir vous allez
zou ming leurs enfants pourquoi ça
descend jusqu'à l'habitat mais attendez
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon c'est bon
la région est trop
sage et ses impasses et suivi j'ai un
petit peu en vue d' ignorer en ce moment
oui parce qu'il avait fait une grosse
boulette je crois que nos
téléspectateurs doivent le savoir qu
avait fait une grosse boulette est parti
raconte quand même à layrac annoncé pour
doute en a parlé
vous avez payé votre départ la société
pendant ce temps d où vous avez payez
vous avez fait 12 ans victor ont parlé
du kiss cool on était la défense et à
mort qui s'était quand même moi je vais
pas revenir là dessus en même temps en
plus c'est bon je vais terrain de temps
dont je peux pas vous fait du bien mais
en même temps bon ben là j'en ai pas
facile et altier collectif mais ça
c'était assez collectif vous allez voir
on a fait déjà deux périlleux tout à
l'heure on a parlé beaucoup ensemble et
ça va mieux d'ailleurs étaient venus
pour essayer de bien mais habité specter
8 janvier pour la prochaine émission
laurent 96 vous repiqué au truc vous
faites sous le soleil le vieux rêve
tropéziens ont s'exhibe le jouet ont
fait la fête la nuit nous connaissent et
savent aussi ça je dois vous quitter le
plateau en plantant tout parce que je
pensais que sous le soleil ce serait en
tout cas sur le papier ça a l'air
intéressant et puis quand j'y suis allé
je me suis pas amusé deux mois de
tournage 50 jours j'ai dit basta ça
suffit
mais après vous êtes retrouvé excusez
moi un peu dans la merde des [ __ ]
j'suis barjots j'aurais jamais dû je me
suis dit tu prends un risque et n'a
jamais dû lâcher tout ça vous dit le
soir des fois je me couchais avec une
casquette un manteau vous aviez frazetta
de chauffage été désigné à dire que
quand on te reconnaît dans la rue quand
on tâte et de d'autres connaissent de
dos tu sors un pied on dira c'est le
pied de mât l'ordinateur c'est la boue
c'est pas le pire et le plus connu
mais vous remplacez la drogue avait ce
moment là par la méditation voilà
c'était au niveau des émotions on peut
s'en sortir on peut s'en sortir
non je dis à kad et olivier qui est et
on peut y arriver il faut méditer bien
est-ce qu'on peut pas s'accrocher à la
méditation
ben j'ai arrêté d'en fin j'ai passé la
situation j'ai arrêté de faire des
retraites parce que je fais des
retraites de silence en fait j'en ai
fait quatre en deux ans donc complet
silence pendant 11 jours à une heure de
paris
non c'est pas des gourous des machins à
une heure de paris à laroche migennes et
en fait c'est génial parce qu'on est
vraiment confronté à soi il allait voile
se lève et c'est l'horreur quoi la
découverte est terrible et en regardant
le smic ne peut pas parler bambin de
temps 11 jours dont ce jour on médite 15
heures par jour et on bouge pas pendant
15 heures et là tu es dans l'instant
présent et tu te dis merde la vie c'est
pas du tout ce que je croyais et c'est
une bonne claque en seront faits soit
mauvais du tout parce que c'est pour que
les énergies
voilà tu vois c'est à dire que l'énergie
tu fais ton cerveau en fait un espèce de
lasers et toute l'énergie tu t'ouvres en
fait toute l'énergie ressort par les
extrémités de quoi pour tout expliquer
rapidement
frédéric 11 jours 15 heures par jour
sans parler je prépare aussi là ça vous
tente
tu peux péter quand même pas
nan mais tu rates tu voyais bien parce
que c'est un terreau pendant un jour
pour arriver à ce résultat
exagéré au bout de onze jours non mais
c'est un acheteur sa parcours et je
trouve assez les sens et ça c'est bon
mangez moi je n'ai pas vu l'épisode de
new look tout ça d'ailleurs je met un
petit pas qu'est ce que pour moi j'aime
pas tous qui nichent en tout ça ça
m'intéresse pas non les oliviers vote
par oui non mais votre parcours est
assez assez assez intéressant
sérieusement on s'est vraiment c'est
balèze comme un homme par you je vous
salue il faut maintenant du 1er janvier
mais aussi une
de lange qui s'appelle une portique
mais film de claude lelouch qui
s'appelle une pour toutes avec marianne
denicourt alessandra martinez anne
parillaud olivia bonamy jean pierre
marielle françois perrault samy naceri
c'est très marrant je vous conseille d'y
aller maintenant j'accueille un auteur
qui s'appelle yann andréa
yann andréa bonsoir alors je vous
présente nos amis donc jean luc
mélenchon j'étais sénateur pas rien
c'est entre un sénateur et le neveu de
l'ancien président de la république
n'est quand même pas mal mallaury nataf
j'ai complètement changé de vie qui
maintenant fait de la méditation
toujours sans culottes et du théâtre l
évaluation voilà qu'elle est olivier
donc monsieur la situation et ses listes
linda hardy et jean pierre landry alors
qu'andrea blanc on peut dire que vous
avez passé sept ans de votre saison de
votre vie avec marguerite duras et on va
essayer de voir comment s'est passée
cette histoire que vous raconter dans un
livre qui est paru chez pauvert et qui
s'appelle cet amour la zumba garçons
zoom zoom zingaro bel et bien alors je
vous ai préparé un petit sampler
non
faut dire que marguerite avait quand
même douté de votre aîné de 38 ans donc
non moins que ça - axa combien j'aime ça
moix alors votre vrai nom vient
d'embrasser yann le mais vous êtes né en
52 le 24 décembre juste avant minuit est
une sorte de jésus vous étiez étudiant
en philo à caen et un jour vous lisez
les petits chevaux de tarquinia de
marguerite duras et vous êtes fasciné
par la lecture de ce livre très belle
histoire et vous avons donné tous les
autres livres pour lire seulement des
livres de marguerite duras vous
rencontrez duras dans un débat je
raconte à je vous pose pas de question
que c'est une histoire soir d'autres
bouquins où il le sait donc je vais vite
vous rencontrez duras dans un débat à
caen où elle vient à l'occasion de la
projection digne à son goût au cinéma
lux et vous lui demander une dédicace et
son adresse
à partir de là vous lui écrivait et
comme d'autres d'ailleurs mais vous vous
décrivez sans cesse sans arrêt et sans
attendre de réponse et sans recevoir de
courrier non plus de la part de
marguerite duras et un jour elle vous
envoie un livre l'homme assis dans le
couloir est surpris de recevoir un lit
parce que vous avez jamais rien reçu de
marguerite duras vous cesser de lui
écrire et là elle vous envoie un mot et
en 1981 la rencontre la deuxième
rencontre enfin lieu vous allez aux
roches noires à trouville prendre un
verre et vous ne partirez plus elle
avait 66 ans vous deviez 28 vous ne vous
quittera plus jusqu'à la mort de
marguerite duras est-ce que ce que vous
avez expliqué pourquoi nous avait jamais
écrit pendant cinq ans j'ai pas de
réponse sûrement la seule réponse était
de jeu viennent et que je reste donc là
le mécanisme est en mars était le
mécanisme de prise de possession par un
écrivain d'un personnage personnages
qu'on s'entend alors à partir de là elle
décide de tout ce que vous faites ce que
vous ce que vous mangez c'est ça oui
comment ça se passe et c'était vous
étiez je dis pas soumis quand même
c'était aussi dans quel état d'esprit
vous étiez par rapport à elle
vous acceptez facilement espèce de
dictature intime n'auront dictature
c'est des mots non non c'était pas
l'esprit non nettier son serviteur mais
margueritte bien on avait l'habitude des
boys et les colonies oui l'indochine
qu'un serviteur fidèle très oui elle
aussi ouais c'était pas facile de vivre
avec elle parce qu'elles n'étaient pas
toujours toujours facile à vivre s'est
mis c'est rien de le dire bien peu avare
d x est connue elle fénié de soupçonner
il vous soupçonne être avec elle pour
l'argent et elles vous disais vous
n'aurez rien ben oui c'est ce qui est
arrivé
babs et quand même 10 % des droits
d'auteur oui enfin oui non bonjour
onze jours à caen hélas non ce qui est
extraordinaire dans votre histoire yann
c'est que vous devez un personnage de
duras d'ailleurs yann andréa steiner et
c'est une s'étaient tous font vraiment
c'était un peu un vivacom comme j cet
avis va arriver mais on a quand même
vécu mais vous vouliez partir certaines
fois vous y arriviez pas vous reveniez
toujours oui je ne venais pas possible
de vous séparer qua non elle vous
faisait recherché aussi
oui enfin je n'étais pas loin qu'importe
rose c'est ça on se dit une force
d'amour comme ça on aime ou peut-être
qu'on l'a pas connu qu'on aimerait le
connaître mais sur le plan humain c'est
terrifiant
vous êtes un montre comment vous attends
attends jours par les empires isation
pareil d'un autre par l'autre dans
l'amour il me semble que dans l'amour il
ya quelque chose on donne on reçoit et
que je fais égalité et ça vous vous êtes
vous démarrez vous vous dites vous-même
ou jettent dehors dit on au tofu dehors
et tu revenir à la rive souvent vous
savez bah oui c'est pas ça le soir est
décent ou sa part été mais c'était pour
tout le monde en tout cas les histoires
voulez vous savez a rendu
non c'est pas le cas d'être heureux
existent l'amour c'est pas pour être
heureux parce que d'amour c'est pas
seulement ça c'était autre chose c'était
le livre à écrire la relation avec elles
au fond c'était ça ça passait par ce
qu'ils avaient à écrire les films à
faire les pieds de tf1 et vous aimiez
une personne ou une institution unique
version de la personne bonhams une
personne et menacer une personne qui
écrivait justement ça pose la question
de qui est qui et comment ça comment ça
se passe mais de 2 degré d'intimité avec
n est pas très vous appelez vous
l'appeliez pas marguerite vous l'appelez
comment je ne souhaite pas vous tutoyez
pas par exemple
moi non mais louis ah bon voulez vous
voyez oui ça dure et saison donc pendant
16 ans de l'été son ami son assistant
son chauffeur et viviez avec elle sans
rien faire de bon si j'avais beaucoup à
faire avant être avec elle c'est il dit
vous raconter l'anecdote tous quelqu'un
vous dit qu'est ce que vous faites ils
vous répondent oui je ne fais rien et
les le dit très bien c'est très bien
vous ne faites rien ouais c'est vrai
quand je faisais rien au fond oui
j'étais là vous pensez que vous étiez
celui qu'elle attendait pour rechercher
sa vérité puisqu'elle est sur la
recherche de la vérité
peut-être alors on mars 96 elle
elmer et vous dites je suis presque mort
avec elle j'ai honte de survivre à cette
mort donc c'est un amour quand même très
très très très fort vous installer en
face de l'endroit où vivait avec elle à
paris cette fois donc dans un studio
partager vos deux valises à tête d'un
studio et vous sortez plus vous cherchez
à vous tuer vous y arrivez pas dont vous
en déduisez voulait pas vraiment vous
tuer vous appelez votre mère qui vous
qui vous ramène chez elle mais vous
restez chez votre mère quelques mois
vous rentrer à paris quelques mois plus
tard le jour de la sainte marguerite et
là vous renfermez dans ce studio et vous
écrivez donc ce livre magnifique cet
amour-là kivu
versant et voilà et maintenant alors
qu'est ce qui se passe je suis là
maintenant je peux dire c'est ce que
vous avez le sentiment depuis la mort de
faim depuis la mort de marguerite duras
mais depuis la publication de ce livre
que tout est dit que la messe est dite
vous jouer les prolongations
ou est ce que vous espérez que la vie
vous apportera d'autres choses
forcément puisque je vis encore joué
mais lui choses aussi forte vous mais
peut-être je sais pas vous n'êtes pas
pessimiste par rapport à ça vous pensez
pas que votre histoire et votre histoire
est derrière vous mais non justement de
l'olive dit qu'elle est présente
l'histoire et que c'est pas parce que
quelqu'un est mort continuent à lui
écrire voilà ouais alors aujourd'hui
comme je disais tout à l'heure j'ai 10 %
des droits d'auteur de son exécuteur
littéraire c'est des problèmes dont on
ne va pas parler ici parce que c'est la
cuisine c'est le cas de le dire
d'ailleurs
la cuisine éditoriale avec son fils jean
mascolo justement sur un bouquin qui
s'appelle la cuisine de marguerite alors
j'ai noté 3,4 phrase de marguerite duras
marie diaz est d'utiliser le monde
entier voudraient être à votre place
oui ouais vous pensez que les libéraux
n'ont pas tout le monde peut-être pas
bruce willis comment tom cruise oui et
quand elle vous disais c'est pas moi que
vous aimez c'est duras oui alors à votre
avis manon s'étaient mélangés
c'était pas mal quand même décroché sa
way rally lucidité bon maintien en dhr
la remercie beaucoup donc je rappelle le
titre de votre livre cet amour là chez
pauvert merci voilà merci d'être venus
bientôt jean luc mélenchon merci je
savais que les deux merci maintenant je
vais accueillir
sur l'ol
m
[Applaudissements]
tu
je suis jeune
ceci il
[Musique]
sont pas du sud soudan
m
soit
soit je râle
je la connais michel dépêche
bonsoir
pas de rome je m'empêche de pouvoir
rendre cette rapide hommage mais quand
on écoute tout ça on se rend compte à
quel point vous avez été important dans
la chanson française j'ai vraiment quand
on entend ça on peut qu'être admiratif
formidable gentil une façon un peu
étrange d'accueillir un invité mais je
crois que pour vous c'est la meilleure
en tous les cas c'est sympa vraiment
merci bien alors vous êtes là parce que
vous sortez à vous ressortez d'abord un
best-of avec tous ces titres et puis un
nouvel album donc ils s'appellent cadeau
de noël qui est là voilà
qui est sortie d'un single s'appelle
cadeaux de noël et le cd s'appelle qu'à
noël et c'est un bon cadeau de noël
voilà donc tout ressort en ce moment on
est heureux de voir en forme avec avec
la pêche
vous connaissez nos amis bah oui j'ai
fait connaissance voilà ma l'original
n'a donc qu'à des ogives et qu'on ne
présente plus voilà linda hardy frédéric
mitterrand vous dit en parlant de se
disent que c'est mon disque plus
accompli depuis les années 70 oui moi je
trouve pas forcément ici enfin c'est mon
avis personne 2010 est sorti depuis
longtemps 8 que ça ressemble c'est le
plus ressemblant la musique à ce que
j'aime et ce que j'écoute comme musique
chez moi et c'est vrai et je vous
souhaite qui marche aussi bien que les
que les morceaux concernant tour alors
que ce que j'écoute voilà dans c'est
marrant parce que rien ou quoi dessiner
être chanteur au départ un mode père
était artisan dans la galvanoplastie
donc au départ c'est pas vraiment
quelque chose qui vous prédestinait à
devenir chanteur 1 et la maison surtout
qu'on écoute et tino rossi juste mariano
chez dell pèse donc voila mais vous dans
votre coin vous écoutiez brassens bécaud
aznavour quelques chansons d'aznavour
vous ont le plus marqué tu te laisses
aller il faut savoir si magnifique tout
beaucoup de chansons j'ai adoré ce jour
j'aime toujours autant bien sûr mais
c'est vrai que ça a été pour moi
déclencheur quoi alors un jour j'ai pas
comment c'est arrivé vous êtes au lycée
de pontoise fêtes de fin d'année il ya
l'histoire c'est quoi il ya un directeur
artistique dans la salle qui s'en
aperçoit pas ce que j'ai en version qui
serait un des pions du lycée qui
maillent qui était d ailleurs champion
de france de saut en longueur par la
même occasion vrai et il s'appelait
lemahieu et ils avaient ils avaient
décidé de 2,2 me propulser un petit peu
afin de me faire connaître des gens lui
connaissait pas grand monde non plus
mais il s'est battu pour qu'on rencontre
directement artistique en scène tandis
qu'un jeune wolson
ah bah oui voilà il nous a face à vous
non molson c'est les mecs a lancé
dutronc déjà ses disques vague disent
que c'est lui qui a lancé antoine enfin
d'asseoir les problèmes françoise hardy
enfin je sais pas si il nous regarde
mais c'est un type g20 comme drucker
mais je commence maintenant je vais
finir ordinaire il faut que je me méfie
mabon enfin en tous les cas jacques
bolson est un mec bien
alors là vous faites trois morceaux qui
n'ont pas été et ne sont pas
impérissable anatole en fait semblant
j'aime la vie voilà ce qu'à mieux
marcher ses bottes qui vous ai fait une
comédie musicale à cette époque l'apsap
les plus attrayants enfin c'est quand
même resté six mois la vie je suis
débrouillé j'étais pas mal ça nous a
permis de rencontrer votre première
épouse chantal simon et alors là vous
écrivez chez laurette alors ce qui est
extraordinaire avec cette chanson c'est
que vous l'avez écrit d'une traite dans
le train de paris à saint cloud et oui
c'est la seule d'ailleurs que j'écris
tout c'est plus dur c'était plus que ce
qu'on peut dire sans être désagréable
avec vous c'est vrai que c'est une
période alors quand même au début de
votre carrière très très agressive
mallory nous disait tout à l'heure moi
j'aurais tuer père et mère pour être
célèbre c'est laid pour faire ce métier
pardon pour faire ce métier c'était
quelque chose de magique moi j'ai acheté
une lune inatteignable et on fait faire
un gars c'est une quatre jours après je
suis sur un plateau par des drogues et
michel c'est vrai michel déclaré que ce
cdd malheureusement enfin
malheureusement pas malheureusement
parce que j'ai dépassé tout ça mais tout
ça c'est dit vous avez dit j'avais soif
d'être connu d'avoir ma photo dans sl
c'est vrai il est on vous a vu
semaine dernière jean marie périer qui
étaient là quand vous étiez en vedette
américaine nous disiez géant tournée je
fais tout pour avoir autant de succès
que la vedette
c'était vraiment elle avait vraiment là
bas j'avais envie de leur média rives et
manifester un peu sinon j'avais envie de
tout fracasser j'avais besoin qu'on
parle de moi ça c'est juste qu'on pense
à ce système la seule motivation je
connaissais rien à la musique à l'âge
sombre seule motivation c'était que ça
fonctionne ainsi que j'étais sympa non
métier de chanteur vous paraissez sympa
parce qu'avec des filles on gagnera
c'était facile
j'ai fait des trucs incroyables squeeze
et je demandais aux attachés de presse
de mettre le paquet je montrais même des
choses de ma vie privée vous avez fait
une photo nue avec vos enfants dans les
six paraît quand même
oh c'est pas très brillante non mais bon
ça va il ya prescription
non non on pouvait s'en passer il ya des
gens qui n'ont pas fourni
vous auriez dû vous moi j'ai posé j'ai
vu dans la grosse émission avec juste un
petit cache sexe debout sur un swing
pour donner dans l'émission de je sais
plus qui c'était moi j'ai posé dans la
caravane magazine ecms est fière moi nu
toujours bien même temps moi je
comprends ce que des michel on a un peu
le même parcours
on a commencé tous les deux mais trois
mois j'étais dans le train de jouer les
riches et leurs doubles six contrôleurs
et ses 7 cm en fait attend lui lors être
mais c'est hélas il était michel delpech
qu'on voit là très calme très sera
atteint la maturité ce qui me gêne c'est
quand j'entre dans un lieu public et ne
pas être certain qu'on me reconnaisse et
quand il ya des gens qui me demandent ce
qui m'énerve c'est quand les gens qui me
demandent des autographes on dit on qui
en dix ans qui s enfin c'est quand même
c'est ouais c'est donc non ça c'est
vraiment les époques
non mais j'ai pas encore une fois c'est
vrai notre 75 av ou premier problème
d'abord avec votre femme première épouse
chantal simon qui la défense un peu vous
avez pris un peu de pelé suis même pas
oui c'est bien c'est full ring a sorti
de notre ville
16 est ce que c'est parce que vous aviez
peur de pu rester en haut vous avez
commencé à vous défoncer un peu ou pas
ce que votre femme annonce non non non
non non généralement c'est ça bien avant
je vous disais à l'époque si j'avais un
second dira que je baisse donc avec
plaisir d'être en haut mais quand on est
en haut le la peur que ça s'arrête quoi
mais c'est pas là en train de vous
écrire à personne
dès que la jeunesse vous ai pris
conscience aussi michel à cette époque
un peu du côté dérisoire d'être un
chanteur de charme une idole ddd des
mines est non dérisoire non en fait
c'est pas vraiment dérisoire d'autres
chanteurs de charme sur donne 10 notre
vjepa sa dérisoire si à l'époque à
l'époque était dur avec les chanteurs
français
il a fallu attendre la fin des années 70
pour ont commencé à admettre
michel berger des gens comme ça parce
que avant ça c'était il fallait qu'il
soit anglo saxons les chanteurs oui moi
j'ai été très marqué par le par le le
succès de pour un flirt en fait ouais
qui mate qui a navigué pendant très
longtemps comme chanteur tube ça ça a
été un peu pénible à vivre pour moi
parce que j'étais bon j'avais envie de
montrer autre chose que je savais faire
mais voilà alors après donc vous avez
connu un trou noir vont sur lequel
repasse et tente beaucoup mais la grosse
vague hausse des prix morlaàs et plus la
rigolade
c'est là la grosse déprime cure de
sommeil quelle heure on se raccroche à
ce qu'on peut les voyant les marabouts
les gourous ya même un sacré bien même
un psychiatre pour comme on doit dire
d'aller dans son cas plutôt un boucher
qui vous a proposé qu'ils aient dit la
seule solution dans votre cas si la
lobotomie il en a parlé j'étais seul et
des espèces de l'hosto 1 4i quai et
j'étais seule il y avait personne pour
me conseiller donc lui dire vraiment
réfléchissez bien
il m'a laissé un soir en disant un côté
réfléchissent et on se revoit demain et
je vous assure que n'ayant moyens vous
sentiez bien désormais c'est de faire
une daube auto mieux possible
et ça maintenant alors j'étais à deux
doigts de lui dire oui parce que à cette
époque j'étais vraiment dans une
situation
ouais et il ya une petite tentation
quand même finalement il ya eu un vieux
gros centre du loir et cher oui c'était
la team un permis de débat ça c'était
sympa de me recevoir aujourd'hui avec
une lobotomie c'est parce qu'on puisse
dire c'est pas ma chance et et alors là
lorsqu'il se passe est extraordinaire
c'est à dire que j'adore les destins se
passe dans cette histoire c'est que il
dit bon je me cassais je pars aux états
unis vous avez vendu vos droits sur le
nombre de chansons voilà qu'ils se
barrent quoi et au moment de partir vous
rencontrer geneviève garnier fabre qui
était une de vos voisines avoue artiste
peintre il a miracle tout recommencer
que sans dire la vie quand même si vaste
qu'elle le dire et là c'est la
résurrection miracle vous venez croyant
en fait un voyage à jérusalem qui vous
marquent beaucoup vous dites je me suis
éloigné du brasier
et voilà et là vous recommencez à
remonter ça vous appris qu'en même temps
pour vraiment vous en sortir je peux pas
je peux pas dire exactement parce que
c'était une longue route près de langnau
ring ding l'aude
mais est-ce que c'était du la question
qui est ce que c'était dû uniquement à
la c'était n'était pas due qu'à la
défense votre état j'étais du tout un
tas de choses à notre vie averti jamais
dire qu'il ya une chose c'est un
ensemble de vingt deux choses s'étaient
pas lié à des choses professionnels donc
c'était vraiment un mal être je suppose
c'était quelque chose qui était en moi
une faille qui étaient là que j'avais
pas remarqué
alors on va terminer là dessus on vous
dit ce qu'on va voir un petit document à
sens et je préfère ma tronche
d'aujourd'hui à celle que j'avais avant
je me trouvais très vulgaire avec mes
chemises à fleurs et mirouf la quête
magnéto serge
[Musique]
es tu
soit
[Musique]
c'est comme un
à ce prix
wight is wight
et puis
lui
dix mois
tu as
[Musique]
mais
m
wwa est plus ou moins
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il
et puis
[Applaudissements]
pêche wight is wight alors qu'elle
stration la série xiii effectivement il
disait j'ai été très con quand j'étais
jeune banon les considérations c'est
vrai en fait tous savent rien
ouais on est on est jeunes qui n'ont pas
cette autre match chose on n'est pas
plus cons là que là et quand tout le
temps bon alors maintenant on va faire
un petit blind test donc si j'ai choisi
les dates puisqu'on arrive chez la
dernière émission avant l'an 2000
c'était un petit peu logique à une
centrale de 1000 donc j'ai pris
uniquement des chansons qui bat avec
sont basées sur des sur des dates vous
êtes près tout le monde peut jouer
qu'est ce que les chaussures de
nouvelles chansons scène son sac les
vôtres cependant je peux donner c'est le
beagle
bien alors tout le monde peut jouer et
le gagnant peut emporter linda hardy ok
moi je joue et je choisis je vais gagner
moi non le gagnant remporte la personne
de son choix
l'accord green d'armes importées mallory
emporté michel faites ce que vous voulez
vraiment porter moi oui c'est bien je ne
joue pas parce que j'ai des réponses
première chanson didier s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
cette année
1962 claude françois la chanson
s'appelle de cette année là mais
forcément la messe et 1062 voilà alors
ont passé la deuxième chanson attention
didier c
il ya des spécialistes
alors que j'ai bossé parce que je sais
qu'il ya lynda lemay je les ai mal au
ring le mec se dit je le motive les mecs
6/10 et linda ses malheurs il a bossé
non c'est vrai qu'il ya des gens en
blind test absolument étonnant fred
chichin de richie besoin de ça il
reconnaît les chansons à la première
note fred 1 on continue à jouer pas
troisième chanson
une mini jupe
le voir corrège
m
j'voulais pas à vide en ville et
il
et
les bienvenus mais cette histoire
en effet
les planches
c'est l'inventeur 66 vraiment
connaissais pas ça sociale bien sûr
l'inventaire 70 jamais il a fait
l'inventaire
il appelle inventé à 62 ans après mais
c'était moi
maintenant on l'a fait comme ça pour
comme ça vous avez michel quand même oui
tu es michel delpech donc inventaire 66
quatrième chanson
[Musique]
regardez olivier incroyable
il soufflait pas je vous en supplie tués
sous jouer pas le sont plus graves que
s'égrènent laisser l'état
69 merci des années érotiques c'est nike
dur parce que la date n'est dit qu'à la
fin c'est une chanson d'antoine dans les
années voilà les années 76 68
oui enfin bref un des 66 une chanson sur
la pilule et la chanson dans le titre de
la chanson y'a l'année de la loi sur la
pilule et la chanson du décès de mario
ce versant cents américains
merci donc je dois dire que c'est une
chanson d'antoine qui s'appelle la loi
de 1905 on entend bien limitation de bob
dylan qui est flagrant évidemment et les
stones ai fait une chanson sur les
modalités elle peur qu'ils étaient sur
la pilule et en prenant le thème des
stones et la musique de dylan antoine
avait bricolé la loi de 1920 et pourquoi
la loi de 1920 à ce que je sois chinois
sur l'avortement qui ont vu l'enfant
continue pour vous parce que mme aigner
voit la loi de 1920 à voir mais comment
vous savez ça vous je comprends pas
pardon comment vous savez lorsque j'ai
géré par les bateaux d'antoine pendant
quelques années maintenant
on a vécu un petit peu ensemble mais bon
je vais pas raconter ma ville sur deux
marins on continue chanson numéro 7 vide
yens
3 17
bref on est
je pense à toi
[Applaudissements]
une chanson de goldman même si sa peine
né en 17 à leidenstadt belles chansons
jamais je suis je suis pour épargner les
bateaux dans un communiqué bien
maintenant chanson numéro 8 des diesels
messieurs attention
m
non
jon
jean delattre avait en tout genre à
s'endormir
gérer c'est ma femme qui fait ça mais
elle est forte
oui non mais je connaissais aussi ouais
mais nationale suisse jean leloup bac 9e
chanson merci oui
oui
alors c'est trop fort mais ça c'est qui
c'est qui c'est qui michel polac michel
legrand 142 encore de nom mais gérait
pas les lunettes de jacques legrand non
mais michel degrange s'étagent et et
avaler pour lui et puis on a longtemps
et c'est moi qui ai inspiré sur le sujet
de 40 de fièvre un jour 49 oui c'est
inspiré cette chanson est ce que
quelqu'un les a donnés les répond pas du
tout à ce qu'il a vu un été 42 allanon
et choqué les bassistes chanson numéro
10 didier 2000
mais oui
[Applaudissements]
non
c'est incroyable jamais vu ça jamais
c'est un enjeu 90b mêmes frais devant la
prochaine mais pas plus c'est sur le dos
de faire jouer sur wii a pas de problème
une analyse avant quand même mon séjour
c'est bon jeu le plus attendu trop
longtemps à toi non vous saviez ça je
vais pas ce qu'on va faire on va
peut-être faire un truc à la maison à
spécial non mais tu vois pas le problème
besoin j'adore ce jeu car adam foote ou
ailleurs peu plus franchement je suis le
cul ouais ouais je sais plus quoi dire
on rallume la lumière ailleurs
bravo aux avocats chaque oeil
notre troisième personnage de noël
fabrice tiozzo
mallaury nataf kad et olivier chabot
linda hardy voilà et donc que vous allez
nous dire le cemi rémy roscoff est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire le poids exact
de fabrice tiozzo ce soir cab
ah oui oui le poids de fabrice tiozzo
alors c'est compliqué c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de chiffres m 90 kg
c'est comme le tueur de linda vous aurez
également la taille de poitrine de
nardis combien 90 ben barka
dimanche matin le pape en face à
marseille tous les deux non propose aux
pme alors fabrice tiozzo bonsoir bonsoir
vous avez déclaré moi je suis pas un
artiste du show-business je suis un
sportif aller faire des grands sourires
sur un plateau de variétés de tf1 à
20h30 c'est pas mon genre je vous
rassure on est sur france 2 il est pas
20 heures 30 on pouvait sourire
alors on vous a invité je vous ai fait
un disque est très étonnant donc ils
s'appellent parole nuit voilà je le
montre la caméra zoome coco voilà vas-y
vas-y voilà alors c'est marrant mais
parole ces belles paroles ni donc ces
textes de jean populiste et c'est un
disque un cd qui a été fait à partir de
l'évangile de saint thomas
c'est à l'évangile qui a été découvert
en 1945 en haute-egypte apocryphe époque
là on est entre gens là ça commence
[Musique]
à suivre c'est la période de l'avent la
cgt castors juniors
ces étudiants c'est du lourd apocryphe
des messieurs le père pour crimes ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est
pas sûr ça veut dire que ça n'est pas
canonique
voilà c'est ça n'est pas homologué voilà
je me lave vaisselle comme vous avez
raison fabrice on a pu demander à la
cades at-on découvert l'évangile de
saint thomas en régie pilori 1945
je vais le dire bien
vous avez dit en parlant de cet album ci
à quelques jeunes qui l'écoutent c'est
déjà bien parce que c'est un album avec
quelque chose dedans avec un message or
j'ai pas la prétention de faire écouter
l'album je faisais juste un petit bout
c'est une sorte de rap non
[Musique]
la journée
jeu blanc
[Musique]
voir mais l'agent
recherché pour passer
ça s'appelle pas en lui donc c'est
fabrice tiozzo et les paroles sont dans
l'album et c'est vrai quand on les
lycées d'assez bon assez bon niveau
oui mais oui voilà non plus et des
paroles tu veux vraiment dire quelque
chose et c'était par le ford est pas
revenu donc c est ce que vous seriez pas
en train de me faire un mohamed allez
vous non non non pas du tout plus tard
vous avez dit ivo sanader il était
boxeur mater les champions d'espagne
avec l'histoire
le mythe est encore nettement nom à
l'épreuve et las vegas
il ya quelques semaines un excellent
boxeur vous y connaissez un peu la bonne
oui vous allez m'aider alors non mais
c'est normal j'ai moi je sais que vous
avez eu 39 victoires et une défaite
c'est ça oui voilà bon vous êtes le seul
français à avoir un titre mondial en
boxe même deux d'ailleurs dans des
catégories tenir deux catégories
différentes qui sont le lait vbc mi
lourds
non non wbc en blu-ray wb a en
lourds-légers aulas voilà je suis là et
voilà ces problèmes de tout le monde
ouais c'est quoi des troisièmes séries
ont donné on apprendre à gagner quelque
chose non pas disons qu'il ya plusieurs
fédérations mais un acte qui sont les
plus ancienne et plus importante c'est
donc la wba wbc et bf est axée trois là
où il faut faire attention les autres
mais moi je l'aï dit il y en a que je
connais pas cette double champion du
monde
oui je la bnp m'a donc quand vous avez
eu city 2010 à l'idée que là j'étais
arrivé à mon rêve je ne pensais qu'à ça
depuis l'âge de 16 ans et là j'y étais
c'était mon obsession on parlait de ça
tout à l'heure delpech vais y arriver
comme ça petit au fil
et puis voilà pigier et et puis après il
ya une sorte de contrecoup
c'est comme un baby-blues les enfants
c'est après mon premier titre
où donc moi j'ai commencé la boxe à 12
ans j'ai toujours voulu être champion du
monde et une fois que je vais arriver à
ça donc c'est vrai qu'il ya plus de buts
je vais enfin moi j'étais arrivé à mon
but ouais et donc après je trouvais plus
la motivation pour m'entraîner pour
faire le régime pour prendre des coups
de poing j'ai plus envie de tout ça et
donc après donc on m'a retiré mon titre
moitié après j'ai retrouvé notre
motivation est donc j'ai une deuxième
chance que j'aie dont j'ai gagné le
combat et maintenant ça marche ça va a
très bien vous n'êtes pas jaloux de
votre frère gspair en mon frangin c'est
mon frère
3 les trois sont dans la base ça le
premier c'est frank l'aîné après
christophe qui est le sien en 90 vous
êtes vous êtes plus petits oui vous êtes
le cadet vous oui hein
or vos parents c'est rigolo on dirait un
titre de film de lelouch il s'appelle
robert et robert et votre père était
fonctionnaire de police
on les prive du basket vous êtes noir
vous avez été levée à samedi à la cité
des courtils quoi et alors vous vous
étiez votre maman vous aimez bien vous
envoyer à l'école le plus tard possible
alors on va plus travailler bien l'école
voilà elle vous a chouchouté maman
beaucoup trop bas 4 ans vous saviez déjà
joué aux échecs
après tout ça vous voulez vous mettre
dans un établissement privé voulez-vous
facile et vous vous étiez quand même
agent ça jean baptiste de la salle
oui tout va tu me disais je voulais
qu'il ait la tête bien faite puis
finalement il a décidé de prendre des
coups
c'est vraiment pour maman alors à cette
école jean baptiste de la salle vous y
avait trop d'autorité pour vous donc
vous êtes ainsi vous allez assez
beaucoup d'autorité encore maintenant
ah oui il ya des moyens dramatique vous
êtes maintenant l'autorité c'est pas un
truc c'est quoi vous voulez être
champion du monde des lourds la semos
mon objectif c'est holyfield le champion
du monde dès lors elle a perdu donc il
arrive un mois maintenant c'est lewis et
de l'accès aux soins est un beau bébé de
2 m et 110 kg ah bon il fallait
reprendre asi voilà non disent oui c'est
bien de champion du monde des lourds
faudra battre avec lagaf d'abord en
mauricie aux origines un truc très
rigolo il a dit j'ai les boules
j'ai les boules depuis l'âge de 12 ans
la haine j'ai beaucoup de points faibles
je suis pas un grand technicien je suis
pas un grand puncheur
mais le mec qui est devant moi il sait
qu'il va passer en toute modestie non
maintenant parce que ça c'est une
histoire encore parce que au départ
j'étais petit j'étais un boxeur moyens
dont on est à l'entraînement tout
n'ouvrit m lego avec moi pour mettre des
coups tout ça et donc non puis j'ai
progressé tout ça le camp vers mon choix
et c'est vrai qu'après donc avec
l'entraînement on s'aperçoit que
finalement la veille lors desquelles
tout petits de qualité qui après gérard
convoité tout s'appuie donc je suis
arrivé à ce à quoi
c'est vrai que votre surnom c'est l'ours
avait alors statué et puis à prendre
pendant longtemps masqué mais lorsque
j'étais à sympa pour un os quand même
non
parce que vous êtes nous annoncer à
l'argentine pas d'accord bien comme
c'est la première fois qu'on se voie je
vous faire une interview première fois
[Applaudissements]
voilà stress en vain je regarde alors
fabrice le premier souvenir
mon premier souvenir premiers souvenirs
de votre vie voilà moi je les comprise
je vais répondre
là
rires c'est mon premier jour d'école
justement si obama veut garder longtemps
tous les jours d'école avait été
terrible voilà vous avez quitté votre
maman c'est sa maman bah oui moi aussi
j'ai un fils une journée scolaire à
l'école bonne première balle
donc vous avez reçus peut-être le même
jour à 9 heures je le vends un coup de
poing vous avez donnez donnez enfin si
je pense que tout le monde à l'école
mais bon à 10 ans j'ai commencé la boxe
là c'était vrai à 12 ans non mais
d'accord donc la seule vraiment j'avais
le droit votre premier péché on y pêcher
les premiers j'en suis à pitre aux
normes la tendance 15 ans comme tout le
monde ça va les filles 14 ans non mais
bon baiser salé c'est la passion de la
vie ça bon écoute foule ses péchés ou
pas les poules et les lapins ces
derniers alors le tout via idole revenir
idol aux battues pense que quand j'ai
commencé la boxe moi je me dirais même
un boxeur que j'aimais bien que je crois
si vous le connaissez mais j'étais de
marvin hagler par une ailleurs ou balade
entre un boxeur dur boxer croisé
voilà maintenant
si on s'intéresse un peu à la boxe en
connaît la tuerie s'est gaussé vous
gaver dit je voudrais être si célèbre
qu'elle foncé halimi qu'on parle de moi
comme d'alphonse allais me non je
voulais jeune homme passionné ça il ya
un rambo crown un problème toujours en
habitant l'an 2000 et en parle toujours
des anciens boxeurs way et ça c'est bon
ils ont fait quelque chose bien tout ça
de maintenant je veux dire fou qui faut
qu'on arrête de parler autant de
millions voire le seul à bord est donc
c'est ce que je dis maintenant si je
voulais voir je veux laisser une trace
dans la boxe comme chardon où aller me
l'ont fait c'est vrai vous avez raison
c'est vrai qu'il ya 30 40 50 ans les
boxeurs cerdan c'est une énorme star
quoi et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui double
champion du monde dont vous êtes
reconnus bien sûr votre nom est connu
mais vous n'êtes pas aussi tard que ça
ouais ouais voilà donc mais avec une
catégorie aussi il est beaucoup moins
deux catégories disons que c'est un
boxeur d'avant les boxeurs d'avant ne
pourrait pas gagner maintenant j'ai un
cd comparaison qui sont qui sont pas
possible de les arrêter
c'est rire toi bien fois
la méditation mon premier amour
non ce n'est mira mourra bas 14 ans j'ai
rencontré ma femme je vous demande pas
votre première expérience sexuelle c'est
complètement complètement
c'est fou ça reste du foot ya eu
tromperie entre tanger mais pas du tout
à l'arrivée ça veut dire c'est que c'est
possible c'est possible plusieurs cas
spécifiques dont c'est un nom du ciel un
homme et une femme dans une vie ça va
mais c'est de cet extraordinaire
c'est par là le riz noir
franchement c'est arrivé à mes parents
mais j'avais 18 ans bonne première cuite
s'en souvenait oui à 11 ans j'ai fait
exprès pour dire voilà mon jour des
pruneaux cuits et vous en avez pris
d'autres après quand même non
quelques-unes le 1er juin
vers 15 ans saison mais ça vous a pas à
brancher gérer c'est pourquoi mais c'est
pas un truc est votre premier dopage a
le droit de ne pas les boxers moi c'est
toujours ce que je réponds je dis donc
si il y en a peut-être d'un cépage le
dos mais il n'y a pas une piqûre on est
un médicament qui peut faire qu'on ait
un viseur qu'on sache où mettre le coup
et où il n'ya pas de piqûre aux
médicaments paraît qui font qu'ils sont
les couples bon c'est pas possible
voilà donc si vous avez merci beaucoup
alors avant de se quitter donc je
rappelle mémoires d'exil frédéric
mitterrand donc c'est la suite des
aigles foudroyés yann andréa qui nous a
quittés pas quitter discrètement s'est
absenté saison donc c'est un beau linge
chez pauvert mallaury nataf alors les
les chants de noël
quand jenson champions
quand les choses autant
et en l'état
je
quoique
et michel delpech donc cadeaux de noël
le titre est tout trouvé en voilà merci
beaucoup merci à tous
l'annoncé mission 19h sur comédie et le
matin dans la période chaude
nous on se retrouve d'abord le dans la
nuit du 31 décembre pour une sorte
d'after du réveillant comme ça sur un
bateau-mouche sur la seine et on se
retrouve dans tout le monde en parle le
8 janvier merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]